[Auto-generated transcript. Edits may have been applied for clarity.]
טוב נתחיל. שלום לכולם!
היום אנחנו הולכים להתחיל פרק חדש שהוא לא יהיה מאוד ארוך.
קצת לדבר על זה בהמשך. בעבר הוא היווה איזה רבע מהקורס.
הוא כיום קוצץ למשהו משמעותית, פחות נרחב, קצת עניין של רוח הזמן ונדבר על זה גם תכף.
אבל למרות זאת, חלק שאני חושב שהוא מאוד חשוב ולדעתי איזשהו חלק יסודי מלימודי עיבוד שפה טבעית, אז התחום הזה בעצם נקרא Department Pussy.
כן או סינטטי, או שהוא בעצם סוג של סינטטי, פירסינג,
ניתוח של תחביר של מבנה תחבירי או ספציפית במקרה שלנו ניתוח של מבנה תחבירי לפי מבנה תלויות בשיטה שנקראת כוח Base.
תכף נדבר עליה. עכשיו, אולי לפני שנצלול ככה לפרטים האלגוריתמים קצת לגבי מה זה מבנה תלויות.
אולי אתם זוכרים מהפעם שעברה או שלא משהו שרוצים להזכיר לנו?
וכן הצעיר נשמע מוכר איכשהו. לא ממש.
אוקיי. בסדר, אז מבנה תלויות.
אנחנו עוד מעט נראה. דוגמאות. מבנה תלויות הם בעצם מכניזם אוקיי הפורמליזם.
סליחה שבאמצעותו אנחנו מתארים מבנה תחבירי של משפט.
איך הדבר הזה עובד בעצם? האלמנט המרכזי בניתוח של מבנה תלויות זה היחס בין גרעין כן אוהד לבין Department, כן.
משהו שתלוי שלפעמים נקרא גם מאוד יפה. היום הרעיון הוא פחות או יותר כזה.
מה זה גרעין? כן. אז כשאנחנו מדברים על צירופים שמנים כן, מה זה סך הכל הדבר הזה?
יש לו הגדרה די ברורה מה זה? מה זה גרעין של ביטוי שמני?
אז אם יש לנו משהו כמו לא יודע האדם הראשון שהלך על הירח או משהו כזה.
אוקיי, אז זה איזשהו ביטוי די מורכב, אבל יש מילה אחת שקובעת את הטיפוס של הדבר הזה.
כן, אם זה יחיד רבים, זכר נקבה.
לא יודע כאילו בעצם התפקיד התחבירי או הסוג התחבירי שלו נקבע על ידי מילה אחת והיא אדם.
אוקיי, זה בעצם האדם הראשון שהלך על הירח הוא מופע של כן או מקרה פרטי של אדם.
אז זה מקרה שאמרנו שהוא יחסית ברור, ואני מקווה שהעיתוי טיבעי להגדיר מהו גרעין.
ואז אמרנו אוקיי, אפשר להרחיב את זה עוד קצת לדבר על קלוזה, אז כן, נדבר על פסוקיות.
אז אם יש לי משהו, כמו כן נרשום את זה.
האדם הראשון.
הלך על הירח.
כן, נגיד למשל נולד. אלה וואטאבר זה 1969.
בוא ננחש כן. 20.
אולי קצת נגיד, אפשר לבדוק אחר כך על ידי לאוסון.
אז אוקיי, לא כל כך משנה אם זה נכון או לא. אז עכשיו יש לנו פסוקית.
נכון, פסוקית אמרנו, נרחיב את המושג של גרעין.
מה יהיה השורש של פסוקית או מה יהיה הגרעין של פסוקית?
אה. אדם לא?
אז אמרנו האדם הראשון שהלך על הירח זה בעצם ביטוי שמני.
נכון זה נאמר. ולא יש גרעין.
אתה צודק שזה אדם. אוקיי, אז בעצם אמרנו שלפני כן אנחנו צריכים לעשות תוך כדי זה הציע.
בוא נזכיר את הא קצת מושגים, שים ודקדוק. אנחנו נשתמש בהם כל הזמן.
דבר ראשון אנו צריכים לעשות תו כניסה ציה. כלומר מה זאת כניסה ארצה?
כן, בדיוק. אז בעצם זה חלוקה לחתיכות שעליהם.
בעצם שאותם נראה כחוליות בודדות בשרשרת.
ספציפית בהקשר של מבנה תחבירי, אנחנו מדברים על מה שנקרא גורמת קבוע ADS.
כן, כלומר מילים או מלהיות כפי שהם מוגדרים לפי.
לפי זה שהם מקבלים תפקיד תחבירי עצמאי ולא לפי.
לא יודע כמה הם מחוברים או לא מחוברים למילה אחרי כן מה שקראנו מילה פונולוגית.
אז נגיד במקרה כאן אנחנו כנראה נפריד את זה למשהו כמו הבן אדם הראשון שזה.
בוא נשים כך אולי זה יותר פשוט. אוקיי, רווח.
שמח. אז ככה ככה. טוב, אפשר מקף ככה סתם, הכל טוב.
ועכשיו אנחנו נצייר. כן. יאללה יש לך.
אוקיי, אז זה נעשה תוך כדי זה הציע. ואז נגיד אוקיי, אז מה הגרעין של המשפט הזה שהוא גם פסוקית?
ואמרנו שנוטים להגדיר את זה בתור נכון?
כן, בדרך כלל זה יהיה הפועל הראשי. דיברנו קצת על יוצאי דופן.
הוא בדרך כלל הפועל הראשון שהיא המשפט שהוא רב נולד.
נכון, לא הלך, הלך. הוא כאילו רמה אחת של קינון מתחת.
כן, רואים את זה. זה לא אדם ראשון הלך על הירח ונולד ב 1920 או משהו כזה.
נכון, זה כאילו חלק מהדור הראשון של אחרי. אוקיי, אז נולד הוא הגרעין של כל הפסוקית ולכן הוא השורש של העץ.
אוקיי, אני מזכיר מה זה מבנה תחבירי של ספציפית מבנה תלויות.
אז זה השורש? בסדר. ועכשיו מה?
תלוי בשורש? אז אמרנו זה כן מה שנקרא Close Elements scan עושה המוסד תיאורים שלילה וכל מיני דברים כאלה.
ספציפית כאן מה כל הסיפור של האתר הראשון שלך?
כל אה כן, כל הביטוי כן כתוב כאן וגם ויש עוד אחד שזה היה ששלחת כן ב 1920.
אוקיי, אז מה אנחנו עושים את זה? איך אנחנו בונים את העץ?
איך אנחנו ממשיכים? החלטנו מהשורש. מה עכשיו חוץ מהשורש הזה?
לאן הוא נעלם? אוקיי, אז בעצם אנחנו עובדים ברקורסיה, נכון?
אנחנו אומרים אוקיי, אם זה תת עץ שמתחת ל נולד, אני צריך לחבר קשת בין נולד לבין הגרעין של תת העץ הזה, שהוא השורש שלו.
מה הגרעין? אדם אוקיי, אז יהיה לנו. חץ.
כזה, נכון? בסדר, וזה עוד חפץ מלבד עצמו.
כן, אז זה גם תלוי בסכמה. נכון, זה כאילו המקרים הקצת פחות ברורים.
אם בבית צריך להיות עם 1920 צריך להיות לא קריטי.
כן, זה תלוי בסכמה. ביוניברסל פיננסית שזו הסכמה שאנחנו בדרך כלל נעבוד איתה.
היא הסטנדרטית, זה 1920. אוקיי.
טוב, בזה סיימנו אותה, את המבנה התחבירי.
יש. אוקיי, אז? אז אוקיי, אז בוא נזכיר, אמרנו שמבנה תלויות תרומה קומבינטורית.
הוא איזה יצור קומבינטור או איזה יצור מתמטי הוא.
באותה עת? כן, שכן. קודקודים הם אמילי או הטוורקינג.
נכון? בדיוק. אז אז קודקודו הם המילים.
במקרה שלנו זה הטורקים. כן, גם אחלה.
אז עוד לא הגענו לזה. נכון, עדיין לא מצאנו את הקודקודים או המילים אלא רק על חלק.
אז בוא נמשיך. איזה עוד חצים פספסתי פה?
אוקיי, נכון, אז אמרנו הדם זה הגרעין. אז בוא נראה מה תלוי נכון מה הם המודל First שלו.
אז יש לך? זה אחד מהם. הראשון כן, גם הראשון.
נכון שהוא עצמו גם מורכב משני תוכן נכון?
או משהו כזה כנראה. אז ככה תראה סכמה שוב, זה קצת עניין של קונבנציות, אבל זה בעצם יראה ככה ואז יהיה לו.
זה יהיה מין תת עץ כזה ככה. אוקיי, אז יש לנו את האדם הראשון.
מה עוד? ואז מעבר מהלך נכון?
אז אנחנו רואים שהלך על הירח גם צריך להיות מאוד יפה.
יער כן. שוב, זה לא הדרך היחידה לנתח את זה, אבל ננסה דרך אחת כדי שנעביר את הרעיון.
אז האדם שהלך על הירח אז שהלך על הירח כולו הוא.
ומה בעצם? איזה יצור דקדוקי הוא פסוקית?
איזה פסוקית? אתם זוכרים איך קוראים לזה? זה בסדר, ולעתים קלונקס קוראים לזה כאן או פסוקית זיקה בעברית.
כן, אוקיי, אחלה. אז כל זה זה פסוקית. אם ככה מה הגרעין שלה הלך?
נכון? הפועל הראשי. אז אדם התחבר לי, הלך למהלך התחבר.
כאילו מה עם המודל First שלו? כן לא זה ביחד כי זה לא על והירח כמשהו נפרד.
כן זה לא. לא יודע.
אתה יודע אם כל כך אפשר להגיד על בלי שום דבר, אבל נגיד, אם היינו עושים באנגלית נכון אז היינו יכולים להגיד ווינדוס באותו back נכון?
ואז יהיה back ממש כיחידה אחת או שאפשר להגיד משהו כמו או back?
אולי זה לא מילה. אני מחפש משהו כזה לחזור מילה אחת כן לא לא סליחה, זה לא הדוגמה שרציתי לתת.
אני רציתי לתת נגיד באנגלית דוגמה של אה אוקיי, נגיד in.
אוקיי, אז אם יש לנו give in כן, אז in שהוא עצמאי נכון?
כי זה מה זה אומר given מקנה נכון? אז אין הוא לא עצמאי כאילו תלוי בגיפ אבל לא מגיח.
הוא לא פרי פוזישן. מה שנקרא לא מגיע אחריו עוד.
אבל אם זה Give in ג'רוזלם או משהו כזה.
לא יודע. It's coming to giving! הוא לא יודע מה זה אומר אפילו, אבל הנקודה היא שם.
זה טרי, פוזישן. בסדר, אז אה, אז אחלה.
אז זה ירח ואז מעל הוא תלוי עליה הירח.
ומה עוד חסר לנו? של הרך הנולד.
כן אשה נכון? צודק! ונולד מתייחס ללידה.
כן, אז הם מחוברים כבר לצלע הזאת. שם יש לי 1920.
אמרנו שאם חילקנו את זה לתוכן אז אנחנו גם איכשהו צריכים שוב.
זה לא בהכרח הצלעות הכי מעניינות, אבל כדי שזה יהיה כדי שזה יהיה ממש ניתוח תלויות קשר, זה צריך להיות עץ מכוון.
אוקיי, על הקודקודים שהם המילים של המשפט.
כן שאמרנו שבילים. ההגדרה שלהם לא כמילה מה שבהכרח בין שני רווחים אלא מילה כן, מה שקראנו מילה דקדוקית אחת.
אגב, אתם רואים שזה עץ. כן, זה לא כל כך נראה כמו עץ, אבל בעצם אם תציירו את זה נכון זה יראה לכם כמו עץ.
כן, זה כאילו אם תציירו את זה כעץ זה יהיה משהו כמו עלה ואז מתחתיו אדם.
וזה לא אמור להיות סליחה נולד סליחה, אדם נולד והאדם זה 1920.
ואז מתחתיו יש במקס או משהו וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
כן, ופה יש עוד איזה עץ. בסדר, אז זה עץ פשוט מאוד.
אבל מה? אז בוא נחשוב איזה.
איזה דבר זה, איזה יצור דקדוקיות זה קטגוריה דקדוקית.
זה הדבר הזה. פסוקית.
אז אמרנו שאנחנו הולכים. זה בדרך כלל היא הפועל הראשי.
כן. חוץ מאולי כל מיני מקרים יוצאי דופן, אז מה?
הפועל הראשי כאן נולד? נכון, כי זה משפט שמדבר על מישהו שנולד ולא על מישהו שהלך.
זה מדבר על מישהו שמתואר על ידי זה שהוא הלך על משהו שנולד.
אוקיי, בסדר. יפה.
אז בניתוח של מבנה תלויות דיקאן סיפרתי בגדול.
יש כמה גישות. אנחנו כן. למעשה.
זה נכון. לא דיברתי עכשיו על למדתי. זה נכון.
חצופים. אז אם ניזכר הם הם לא שוטרים, הם פשוט צירים אחרים.
כן? אז אם ניזכר בזמן ליטיגציה, למה בעצם כן עובד?
נכון, אבל אם אתה זוכר הדרך כן. הצגתי את הדרך הסטנדרטית לנתח בשיעור הקודם.
איך יראה הניתוח? לא, זה לא קל. כן, נכון, זה יראה נגיד ככה.
אז בדרך כלל פשוט עושים את זה בשני טורים נפרדים. כי אתה צודק, אי אפשר.
האחד לא באופן טריוויאלי אומר מה השני ואז בדרך כלל פשוט מייצגים את.
שניהם. כן, כי אתה תכף תראה, אנחנו נרצה לתת פיצ'רים שלפעמים זה זה.
לפעמים זה זה. אולי זה קומבינציה או כל מי אתה תרצה להשתמש בכל הדברים האלה, אבל היינו מנסים.
מבצע הדיפנדר. צי הוא בדרך כלל ברמת אינדקסים, כי תזכור שמבחינתך זה לא שאתה מחבר בין מילה, כלומר המילה כתובה בין ווטפורד.
אתה מחבר בין מופע של המילה הזאת במשפט בגידה הזה.
סליחה הזה הוא לא אותו ה כמו זה.
אז אנחנו עם 3 מבחינת זה שהיא משותפת כמעט לכל אחת.
אנחנו מתקדמים בשלושה צבעים שונים, קצת מופרדים.
מה שבדרך כלל עושים זה כחלק מהפרי process. זאת אומרת, עוד לפני שעשינו קמפיין, סיפר סינג.
כן, אז בגלל זה קוראים לזה Try processing. אתה רוצה לעשות אותו כנזק אם אתה רוצה לעשות אותו, קנזס יעבור דיפנדר, סיפר סינג.
אנחנו נראה בהמשך הקורס שאתה עושה תקני הזיה, לא מהצורה הזאת לצרכים אחרים,
אבל ספציפית לצרכים האלו אתה רוצה תו כניסה ציה לחתיכות שהם יהיו בסוף הקודקודים של עץ התלויות כן של המבנה התחבירי?
כן. ואז אמרנו שבאמת טוב. זה קצת תלוי בסכמה, אבל קצת דיברנו על איך עושים את זה.
לא נורא משנה כרגע. מה שמשנה הוא שאתה בסוף מקבל חלוקה של המשפט בפורמט הסטנדרטי של יוניברסל דיפנדר.
אז אני אזכיר. זה נראה ככה.
כן, זאת אומרת מה שעושים זה נותנים אינדקס. כן, זה לא כזה קריטי, זה הכל.
יש דוקומנטרי באתר? כן, אבל פשוט כי זה יבהיר את השאלה.
אז נותנים אינדקסים למילים. במשפט מילים הכוונה היא כרגע אני מדבר על דברים שנמצאים בין רווחים כן או פיסוק וכאלה.
כן, אז אתם רואים זה? אז בעצם נותנים אינדקסים.
אבל בעצם למקרים שבהם מה שכתוב בין שני רווחים יש שם כמה מילים.
במקרים שיש כמה מילים נותנים לזה כמה אינדקסים לפי מספר המילים כן אז יהיה כתוב כתובת בארמנית המתנוססת.
אז בעצם יהיה כתוב כמו שאתם רואים כאן אחד כתובת שתיים עד שלוש בארמנית ואז שתיים זה שלוש,
זה ארמנית ואז ארבע על חמש המתנוססת, ואז זהה ארבע מתנוססת חמש וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
ולפעמים זה גם שלושה אינדקסים. כן. כן, בכלים ובפירות.
אז 25 27 ואחרי זה כתוב 25 26 ספרות.
אוקיי, וחוץ ולכל אחד יש למה כאילו כמובן אין למה?
לאלה שיש להם כמה אינדקסים כי הם לא מילים לצרכינו.
כן הם לא מילים גרמה תקניות. אז למה בארמנית?
אין למה? אבל לבה עולה ארמנית יש להם כבר בעניין פעולות של פעולות בכל צומת.
זה קובע מה הם הצמתים? המוטציה הזאת קובעת מה הם הצמתים?
בעצם כן אני יכול להצהיר על תוצאות. כן, זה בעצם פיצ'ר לכל צומת.
יש לך את הצורה שהיא כתובה ואת הלמה שלה.
בסדר. אתה יכול להשתמש שבהנחה שעשית גם למטריצה וגם סגמנט.
סגמנט תא ציה 10 עד תו כניסה ציה. אז עשית את שניהם.
יש לך קצת עוד שאלות לפני שמתחילים.
אחלה. אז אז יש לנו. יש שלוש דרכים עיקריות שאנחנו נתקלים שאנחנו נתקלים בהם בספרות.
אני רק מזכיר את זה למקרה שתיתקלו מאמרים שאתם קוראים אני לא הולך.
אין לי זמן לדבר על הגישה של תכנון דינמי ולא הגישה שנקראת רמזי Lion base.
למרות שמי שמתעניין בהחלט אשמח להפנות. אנחנו נדבר על גישה שנקראת גרף בייס גרף בייס, אלגוריתם שהם בעצם אינסטנט של structure production.
אוקיי, בוא ניזכר מה זה structure production. זוכרים?
הזכרנו את זה בעבר? מה ההבדל בין סתם production לבין מה שבדרך כלל קוראים Stack?
ב פריידי שאנחנו מכירים. נכון, יש לי תמונה. אני רוצה להגיד אם זה ג'ירפה או חתול, אז יש לי לייבל אחד ג'ירפה לאימייל, אחד חתול.
אני רואה תמונה, צריך להחליט מה מה. אוקיי, מה זה structure פיקשן?
כן, מה זה אומר לחזות מבנה? איזה דוגמה ראינו כן?
אוקיי, נכון. ולמה? כי את זה אני לא ממש יודע למה בעצם אני רוצה לחזות את האמנים עצמם.
כאילו. המבנה של המשפט נכון ודרך אחרת להציג את אותו הדבר.
את אותו הרעיון זה בעצם להגיד שיש לי כאן. בעצם אני יכול לחשוב על זה כעל הרבה פריטי קצוות שיש ביניהם תלות.
נכון, אני לא רוצה לבצע אידיאלית, אופטימלי.
אני לא רוצה לבצע כל אחד מהם בנפרד. יש קשר ביניהם? אוקיי, זה גם יהיה המקרה כאן ואנחנו נראה מיד למה.
אז כבר כאן? נראה לי שהסיבה היא יחסית ברורה אנחנו רוצים, אנחנו מקבלים משפט נכון ואנחנו רוצים לחזות עליו עץ.
יש כל מיני עצים אפשריים. הנה נגיד המשפט doctors operation patients who cares.
כן, דוגמה דידקטית doctors operation patients with fever.
אז באופן עקרוני העץ הזה היה.
הייתי יכול לכתוב אותו על המילים האלה והעץ הזה על המילים האלה.
ויש גם עוד דבר עצים אחרים שהייתי יכול. נכון, יש מספר אקספוננציאלי.
אם אתם זוכרים מתמטיקה דיסקרטית, אפילו ממש חישבתם כמה יש, אבל לצרכן הוא מספיק שזה מספר אקספוננציאלי של עצים אפשריים עבור אוסף קודקודים.
נתון כן של עצים פורשים נכון עבור אוסף קודקודים נתון.
אז יש פה סט אקספוננציאלי של פרדי קציעות.
אני אומנם יכול לחשוב עליהם ותכף אנחנו נעשה משהו דומה לזה.
כן, אני יכול לחשוב עליהם כעל הרבה פרדי קציעות יותר פשוטות, כמו למשל לחזות בהינתן זוג קודקודים האם יש ביניהם צלע או אין.
בוא נעזוב כרגע את עניין הלייבל, אחרי זה נגיע אליו.
כן, זה שעל צלעות יש להם גם תווית. באופן עקרוני הייתי יכול נכון לשאול אתכם תגידו, מה דעתכם בין Patients לבין wild?
יש צלע? אולי כן בין wild לבין סקאל וכן הלאה.
וכל אחד מהם הייתי שואל אתכם אם יש לכם דיוק של 100 אחוז הייתם משחזרים את העץ?
נכון? אין בעיה, לא צריך יותר מזה.
כמובן שבאופן פרקטי אין אף פעם דיוק של מאה אחוז, ואנחנו היינו רוצים להיות מסוגלים להנות מתוצאות של בדיקת סי אחת כדי לשפר את הדיקציה אחרת.
אז מי יכול לתת ככה טיעון פשוט?
למה זאת בעיה Structure? למה יש כאן תלות בין הדברים?
למה?
אולי זה תת אופטימלי בהינתן שיש לי קצת רעש לחזות כל צלע כבעיית דיקציה בלתי תלויה בדבר דיקציה אחרת, כאילו מתחזית אחרת של השאלה אם קיימת או לא קיימת צלע.
אפילו בלי לדעת יותר מדי על דקדוק. כן, כל אחד בשני אז.
אז למה זה תלוי איך אתה תשכנע אותי? זאת אומרת.
כן. למה יש תלות בין הדברים? למה יש תלות בשאלה אם איי וג'יי מחוברים לעם היי טק וג'יי טק מחוברים?
עבור אתה תבחר את טלוויזיית. יכול לתת לי זוג צלעות עם שדיים או אוסף צלעות.
לא חייב ארזו כן שברור שהוא תלוי. אוקיי.
אוקיי, אתה אומר תוכנית? מבחינת הגמר זה נראה קשור, נכון, אבל אפילו טיעון עוד יותר פשוט מזה.
כן, אחלה. זה כיוון מצוין. אנחנו תכף נדבר עליו. כן, אבל אפילו תחשבו.
פשוט פשוט. כן אומרים טוב טוב, ברגע שאתה אומר לא, זה משהו אחר.
אוקיי, נכון, אז כל הדברים האלה הם דברים נכונים, אבל כאילו אני רוצה לשאול אתכם מן שאלה כזאת הרבה יותר, כאילו שלא קשורה אפילו לגרמניה.
בסדר, תעזבו את סין תחביריים אתם. יש לכם אוסף קודקודים ואתם רוצים לחזות עץ עליהם בסדר?
עץ עץ פורס על הקודקודים האלה. בואו תשכנעו אותי שיש תלות בין הפרטים.
הציוץ של האם קיים אצלה או לא. קיימת סלע בן זוג קודקודים.
בסדר, הנה יש לי קודקודים במישור. עזבו אתכם בדקדוק, אבל האם אני שנייה אחת, שנייה שנייה?
אוקיי, אתם עומדים בפני בעיית דיקציה הבאה. אוקיי, יש לי קודקודים, בוא נקרא להם א ב ג דלת.
הם לא קשורים לדקדוק, הם סתם תבנית. לא סתם, אבל משהו לא קשור לדקדוק בסדר.
ואני עכשיו אני מבקש ממכם לחזות את העץ הנכון עבור אוסף הקודקודים האלה.
מה דעתכם? האם פרדי קצין לגבי? אם אני עכשיו אגלה לכם חלק מהצלעות, זה יתן לכם איזשהו מידע לגבי קיום או אי קיום צורות אחרות.
כן. איך? מתי? נא דוגמה.
יש לי סימן א. ב. נגיד יש לי צל לבן. א. כן, עץ מחורבן.
זה לא קריטי. אוקיי, גם הפוליטיקאים הם בין בית לגימיק.
אז ההתמודדות שלהם? הופ? יפה מאוד!
מצוין, נכון? אז הנה אפילו טיעון נורא פשוט, כזה שלא קשור תכף לכל הדברים שאמרת הם נכונים.
כן. אנחנו תכף נדבר ספציפית על דקדוק, אבל אני אומר אפילו ברמה הכי פשוטה.
גם אם אנחנו לא מתעסקים בדקדוק אלא מתעסקים בעצים אחרים לגמרי.
על פניו יש כאן תלות. נכון, ולא מהסיבה הפשוטה שזה אמור לצאת גרף חסר מעגלים נכון וכשיר.
ואם אני כבר יודע חלק מהצלעות אז חלק מהצלעות יסגרו.
מעגל כבר לא יהיה בסדר. יפה.
אז א. זה הסיבה שאנחנו חושבים שזה structure production ואז אנחנו כבר מתחילים אולי לזעזוע בכיסא בחוסר נוחות.
נכון, כי אנחנו יודעים שבעיות דיקציה של Structure צריך לבנות משם איזשהו משהו גנרי.
נכון שיידע לעשות את זה. יש לנו מרחב אקספוננציאלי של אפשרויות.
אנחנו עכשיו צריכים לחפש במרחב הלייב, אז מרחב העצים באופן יעיל כל זה נדבר.
אבל לפני כן באמת קצת נדבר על איזה סוג של מידע היינו רוצים לקודד כן או איזה סוג של פיצ'רים היינו רוצים, מה בת מה, איזה תכונות של המשפט עשויות להיות?
קורא לטיבי אותו אנטי קורא להטביות. אם השאלה אם יש צלע או אין צלע בן זוג קודקודים כן.
וכאן אתם אמרתם כבר. שנייה אחת כאן אתם כבר אמרתם כמה תשובות טובות.
נכון, אחת מהם הייתה נגיד, למשל, שדוקטור ואופיר רייט אני יכול, אפילו אם אני לא מסתכל על שאר המשפט.
נכון להגיד וואלה, שווה אולי לשקול אותה בחיוב?
כי כן, עופרי זה משהו שדוקטור אז הרבה פעמים עושים.
כן, אבל לא ברור שזה טיעון מנצח. אולי זה במקרה הם לא קשורים אחד לשני, אבל בהחלט משהו שכדאי לקחת בחשבון.
כן, זה קוראים לזה לפעמים by לקסיקון הפיניקס. כן, כלומר by לפסיקה, כלומר בין מילים בסדר זוגות מילים אז doctors ו patients הולך טוב.
פציינטים עם הזמנים אולי פחות.
כן, אולי יכול להיות, אבל כן, כנראה פחות יותר.
המנתחים מתעסקים באיזה מלים כנראה. טוב.
אז זה דוגמה אחת. דוגמה שנייה שניתנה כאן כן, שנייה נא מיד, כך שאלה.
דוגמה שנייה שניתנה כאן זה הקשר בין Operation ואון לפשט.
כן, אז כאילו אז אנחנו אומרים תראו, אם אני כבר יודע שיש קשר בין עופרי לאון.
אוקיי, אז אולי מגדיל את הסיכוי. שעון קשור לפי Hans נכון?
כי. עושים ניתוח על פציינטים?
כן, הרבה פעמים. אוקיי, אז בעצם יש כאן גם תלות בין הצלעות.
נכון, תלות בין הצלעות מהסוג לא מהסוג שזה בלתי אפשרי, שאם עופרי מחובר לאון אז לא תהיה צלע בין כאן לכאן,
או שזה שיש כבר תצא לעשות אומר שבוודאות הצלע הזאת קיימת.
לא משנה איך נראה המשפט, לא עד כדי כך. כן, זה לא כמו עם העץ שאמרנו.
א הולך לבית בית הולך אל בטוח. ג. לא הולך לאט.
כן, זה לא ברמה קטגורית, אבל כן סטטיסטית. סורי.
אוקיי, אז זה גם נקודה טובה וגם אותה אני צריך לקחת בחשבון. כן, הייתה שאלה.
כן, אבל קונקלינג טוב, עוד פריט ולא אופייני.
דורסי סומך במינסוטה. יש ביניהם זיקה.
כן. זה כאילו אתה זה מה זה.
כאילו מידע על תוכן נכון? אז מה הביצה?
אוקיי, זה נקודה טובה מאוד, אבל זה נראה לי תשמור אותה לסוף השיעור,
כאילו זה מין משהו כזה של איזה סוג מידע היינו רוצים לקודד כאילו היית הייתי דווקא אם לא היית אומר לי את זה, הייתי אומר לך טוב, א.
טקסטים אז אני די מתעסק בתוכן פלוס. אני לא רוצה להתעסק בתוכן בשאלה.
אז נקודה מעניינת אפשר לדבר נכון?
מה זה כנראה לא נכון. כן.
זה נקודה קצת יותר עמוקה. אני אתייחס אליה בסוף השיעור. תזכיר לי אוקיי.
בסדר. עוד דבר שחשוב זה דיפנדר סי, דיסטנס.
כן, יש לי שתי מילים במשפט אוקיי, המרחק ביניהם, המרחק בין המילים או מה דעתכם קורה לטיבי או אנטי?
קורה כאילו קורלציה חיובית השלילית עם הקיום של הצלע.
שהמרחק בין המילים כאילו כמה טוורקינג יש ביניהם יותר קרובות.
אה, אז ככל שהן יותר קרובות אז זה יותר.
אז מרחק כן, קרבה היא קורלציה חיובית או מרחק רואים קורלציה שלילית לכן.
אז אם נגיד תסתכלו על המשפט הזה פתוח. מי שנזכר בו אגיד שאייכמן מדבר.
מובי טרומן לואיז. אתם רואים שהמשפט הזה יש בו אומנם קצת צלעות לא מאוד קצרות, נכון נגיד גיין וייטס.
העיקר זה יש ביניהם אחת, שתיים, שלוש, ארבע באמצע.
אוקיי, אז אולי זה צלע לא כל כך קצרה, אבל עדיין היא לא היא היא היא היא.
היא גם יחסית חריגה. רובם הם הרבה יותר קצרות מזה וגם היא לא ממש מההתחלה עד הסוף.
לא שאני אומר שהן לא יכולות לצאת מההתחלה עד הסוף, אבל הן יותר נדירות.
אוקי, רוב הצלעות הן קצרות וזה נכון להרבה שפות, לא רק לאנגלית.
בייחוד בשפות שיש להן סדר מילים יחסית נוקשה.
כן, אבל זה בגדול נכון גם בשפות אחרות, אולי בצורה פחות חזקה.
אז אוקיי, אז זה עוד פיצ'ר חזק. אגב, אתם יודעים על איזה פיתוח מתייחסים כאן?
איזה? על איזה פית מדובר? זה בקשר לחומר של הקורס.
מאיפה לקחתי את זה? לא, לא ראיתם את הסרט?
כן. טוב, זה סרט ידוע.
הפעם נראה לי זכה באוסקר תלמה ולואיז. בראד פיט בעצם באחת ההופעות.
כאילו לא נראה לי. נראה לי ממש ההופעה הראשונה שלו, אבל אחת מהמוקדמות שלו כן.
בסדר איתו. Winning Talks.
בסדר, זה אומר איזה מילים יש באמצע? גם זה יכול להשפיע?
למה? כי הרבה פעמים למשל צלעות או לא, הרבה צלעות חוצות, נגיד סימני דקדוק.
אוקיי, אז אם יש לכם סימן דקדוק כמו פיט פס, כן, מי שנזכר which which in the road, מו ויתר מאן לואיז הנסון.
After became world זה ווינר?
לא יודע. Movie star. כן. אז תגיד, יש לך פסיק אחרי זה?
אוקיי, אז אתם תראו שבצורה די הגיונית. החתיכה הראשונה עד הפסיק היא מהווה תת עץ.
כן או לא משנה או זאת שאחרי הפסיק התת עץ או זאת שלפני והיא פשוט תלויה ישירות מהשורש.
כן, אז בעצם אתם. יהיה לכם טה טה טה פסיק. כל משפט טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה טה.
אז או שזה או שפה יהיה לכם תת עץ שיהיה מחובר ככה.
כן וזה ימשיך מפה לחצות את השאר או להפך.
אוקיי, אבל לא. אבל מה שזה אומר זה שאתם לא תראו יותר מדי צלעות שחוצות ביניהם.
אוקיי, אז פסיק זה קונטרה אינדיקציה לקיום של צלע פועל.
גם בדרך כלל אין המון צלעות שחוצות פעלים, אז זה גם יכולה להיות קונטרה אינדיקציה.
בסדר, אז זה עוד עוד פיצ'ר חשוב.
פיצ'ר נוסף זה מה שנקרא ולנסי. כן. אז מסתבר שגם להרבה מילים יש בעצם בעצם סוגי דיפנדר טיפוסיים.
אוקיי, אז אם נגיד אני אכניס פה גם לייבל, זה יהיה אפילו עוד יותר ברור.
וגם באנגלית זה נכון. אז מה אם אני מתכוון, נגיד למשל סליפ בדרך כלל אין לו אובייקט.
אוקיי, אין לו מושא ישיר שבא אחריו. אז אם יש לכם משהו שהוא מושא ישיר ולפני כן יהיה sleep, אז סיכוי לא רע שזה לא העוד שלו.
אולי זה אפילו לא דיפנדר שלו. כן, אפשר אולי להגיד מה שנקרא אקוגנית או ג'קט.
כן, ישנתי את השינה שנמנעה ממני שבועות רבים או אילוף שאולי כן למצוא לא טוען שום דבר, לא בהסתברות אפס.
כן, אבל זה גם נשמע קצת מוזר וזה מאוד חריג.
כן, מאוד נדיר. לעומת זאת לתת כן או תקין כן להרוויח.
בדרך כלל יצוין מה הרווחתם ומי הרוויח וכאלה.
הגיב יש לו הרבה פעמים גם מושא ישיר וגם מושא עקיף.
כן לתת את משהו למישהו כן או באיזושהי צורה בסדר.
להרבה פעלים אחרים לא יכול להיות להם גם שני מושאים כן או כמעט או שוב לא יכול.
זה מין משהו שצריך להיזהר ממנו, אבל פחות או יותר אף פעם לא.
אז גם זה חשוב. פשוט פשוט לנסות ללמוד מאתרים עם Data.
איזה מבני תלויות יש? כן, איזה קונפיגורציות?
איזה אוסף של צלעות יכולות לצאת מן קודקודים מסוגים שונים.
בסדר, ואנחנו עוד מעט נראה גם עוד פיצ'ר איך עושים, אבל יועציה או מה המטרה שלנו.
אז בגדול אנחנו נעבוד כרגיל בסופר בייס Setting.
כן, יש גם אין ספור views products. בזה לא נדבר עליהם, לא נדבר עליהם כרגע אנחנו נדבר על סופר ווייס Settings בפרט.
גם האבולוציה נעשית מול גולד סטנדרט. כן, סטנדרט Partition כמו שתמיד דיברנו.
ואז מה שבגדול עושים זה את יוסי על הצלעות.
כן, את יוסי על הצלעות. כלומר אם יש לכם אין תקנים במשפט.
כן, אתם מקבלים משפט אם תו כניסה הציר, אם זה בלי תו כריזמתי הזה כבר קצת מסתבך.
אנחנו נניח זה תמיד עם תו כניסה הציון אתם מקבלים משפט אם תו כניסה אוקיי, אז זה אומר שמספר הקודקודים ידוע?
כן מה מספר הצלעות לכן? כמה צלעות יש במבנה תלויות?
משפט אם אין תקנים. מינוס אחד אין מינוס אחד.
כן נכון, הם מינוס אחת צלעות. אז המספר הוא קבוע ידוע.
ברגע שראיתי את התוכנית זזתי. אני כבר יודע כמה צלעות. ועכשיו אני פשוט אבדוק כמה צלעות.
מבין המכונות הצלחתי לפגוע בהם. אוקיי, זה מספר הצלעות הנכונות חלקי מספר בעצם מספר המילים.
הסיבה לזה זה כי אנחנו בדרך כלל מוסיפים דמי node. כן כמו כאן root כאילו.
כי אחרת היה יוצא שאנחנו לא נותנים לזה שהצלחנו לזהות את שווה או לא הצלחנו.
לא נותנים איזה ניקוד בנפרד. בגלל זה בדרך כלל מוסיפים עוד דמי כזאת בין ROOT לבין לבין מילת השורש.
כאן המילה היחידה שאין לצלע נכנסת ואז פשוט אפשר להסתכל קורקט.
Here חלקי מספר המילים זה יהיה האקורד. סי נקרא גם attachment score ולפעמים מדברים על לייבל בצד שמאל סקור ואני בצד שנזכור שזאת בושה.
השאלה פשוט אם יש גם לייבלים.
כן, אז זה נגיד צורה שהוא הצורה של הטורים שכבר ראינו קודם, שהיא מאוד נפוצה בהקשרים האלה.
אז אנחנו מסתכלים על Gold. כן, נגיד שזה אוסף הצעות או קיי, אחד הולך אחד או דיפנדר של שתיים שתיים הוא די בן,
הוא הוא שורש, הוא טיפונת של אפס, כאילו ערוץ שלוש, חמש וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אנחנו מסתכלים על הפוסט.
כן, מה שחזינו, בודקים כמה, מה גודל החיתוך חלקי מספר המילים, ועכשיו אנחנו בודקים שני סוגי חיתוכים אחד, כשאנחנו גם דורשים שהליברלים יהיו אותו דבר.
בהנחה שאנחנו חוזים לייבל עם רצועות. כן, אז אין sub אין sub.
זה אותו הדבר וזה אחד שתיים אז מעולה. אבל נגיד ארבע חמש זה כאן.
אין אין. ופה הוא גם ארבע חמש בפאפוס.
אבל הוא חזר משהו אחר. אז זה יהיה לייבל קיט אס לך אן אן לייבל Heat.
אבל לייבל מיקס אוקיי. סופר פרסומות.
אוקיי, אז זה מה שאנחנו מנסים לעשות למקסם את מספר הצלעות.
כלומר, מה שמאוד חשוב לצרכן או להדגיש הצלחה חלקית נחשבת בדרך כלל כן, זה לא אפס או אחד.
כן, זה לא שאם אחד הצלעות בעץ לא עשיתם פונקציה נכונה אז פספסתם את הכל.
בדרך כלל הדרך המקובלת זה לחשוב על זה. כן, אוסף של צורה שיש ביניהם תלויות כמובן כמו שדיברנו.
אז מה הגישה בגדול הגישה בכל הגרף Blast Sing.
כן, וגם ספציפית באלגוריתם הראשון שנראה תכף שנקרא ה must פרסר.
כן המקסים. הספינינג שלי פרסר זה בעצם הגישה הבאה אנחנו לוקחים את אוסף הקודקודים.
נגיד שאוסף הקודקודים שלנו זה ג'ון מרי, ג'ון מרי וסול.
אוקיי, שם ג'ונס אומר זה המשפט לא, אלה התוכניות בסדר, משפט פשוט רק לצורך אילוסטרציה אנחנו מסתכלים על אוסף הצלעות האפשרי.
כן, שהוא בעצם גרף כמעט מלא על ג'ון מרי ושאר פירות.
כן, אני אומר כמעט מלא. למה כמעט כן בדיוק לראות לא נכנסות צלעות, אבל חוץ מזה הוא מלא לגמרי כל הצלעות הפוטנציאליות.
ועכשיו מה שאני מנסה לעשות זה למצוא לגרף הזה תת גרף.
כן, או בעצם תת גרף שהוא עץ פורש, שהוא יהיה אופטימלי לפי איזה שהיא הגדרה של אופטימלי שאנחנו.
תכף נראה שיש כמה גישות לגבי מה זה אומר אופטימלי.
אז זה הרעיון. אנחנו בעצם רוצים ללמוד איזושהי דרך לתת ניקוד לעצים, פורשים שונים של גרף כל הצלעות האפשריות ולבצע פרי דיקציה,
אוקיי, לבצע פרי דיקציה שתמצא לנו את תת העץ הפורס אה.
שם ממקסם את את הסכום ספציפית בגרסה הפשוטה ביותר של הגישה הזאת.
מה שאנחנו עושים זה פשוט. אנחנו מניחים שמשקל של תת עץ הוא כסכום משקלי הצלעות, שזה גם בדיוק מסתדר.
אם אתם זוכרים שלמדתם על מקסימום ספלינג פרי או מינימל Spend שהיא לא משמידה אותו אותו דבר.
כן? אז אם אתם זוכרים, זה היה בדיוק ההגדרה של משקל של עץ פורס שם.
כן. אז מה? מה הכוונה יש לי אז תחת ההגדרה הזו כן ה must partner approach.
תחת ההגדרה הזאת אנחנו צריכים לתת משקל לכל צלע, לא לכל העץ כולו, כי פשוט משקל העץ כולו מתפרק כסכום משקלי הצלעות שמכילים אותו,
ואנחנו רוצים למצוא עץ פורש כך שסכום משקלי הצלעות שנבחרו לעץ הפורס יהיה כמה שיותר גדול.
וזה עוד מבוסס על עבודה של ראיין מקדונלד, קובי קרמר ופרננדו פריירה מ 2005.
עבודה מאוד משפיעה בתחום. בסדר, אז אחרי ההפסקה כן, אחרי ההפסקה אנחנו בעצם נלמד למה הפורמולה ציה הזאת.
אינפורמציה שנוח לעבוד איתם, להציע אלגוריתם ספציפי לגבי האופן שבו אנחנו לומדים את פונקציית המשקולות האלה, את הפונקציה שהם ממקסם את עצמו.
ואז אנחנו נדון במגבלות של הגישה הזאת, ונראה גישות שיכולות לענות על חלק מהמגבלות במחיר של משהו אחר שהן מפסידות.
אז אוקיי, נתראה עוד רבע שעה. בית.
רוצה. החיפוש.
אחר. שירות.
אה כן, לגבי ההפקה כן רק עכשיו.
מה שאומר שעכשיו אני מבין מה שזה אומר.
אני ויתרתי לעצמי ועל זה. זה משהו אחר.
אנחנו בעצם נפגשים איתה סמוך לשעה ולא שואלים שאלות למה הוא לא מתעניין?
ונותנים ציון. אז עכשיו מה שאני מנסה להגיד זה הרבה פחות סטנד אפ והדברים כל אחד קצת.
גם היחס אחר מתפספס דברים כאלה.
יש אנשים שאוהבים את זה יותר. זה שיש אנשים שלא מכירים אותם אז.
זה תלוי בבן אדם בגילך.
איך זה יכול להיות? זה כאילו יכול להיות. אנחנו בעיצומו של משבר כלכלי כי אנחנו מדברים על זה וזה שנה כי אנחנו מדברים.
אז כאילו שאלות במבחן זה שעתיים במבחן ואז הרבה מהזמן של שעתיים זה פשוט ולשבת ולחשוב על השאלות.
זאת אומרת אני לא חושב שהשאלות הם במבחן, אז יש ערך מוסף מבחינה.
אז כבר עדיף לעשות בחינה. זה בסדר.
אז כאילו אתה רואה שאתה קצת פחות כאילו, אבל את יכולה.
אם את עושה מילואים מזווית גימל גם כן הפניה את על זה שפשוט לא הולכים.
זה לא קונספט שניסה להסתיר את הבגידה החמה שהייתה עכשיו.
אז כל חרדי או אדם שהיו.
זה מתחיל להוציא גימל, אז גם השם שלי ממש מזכיר.
ממש הולך להיות לי מצב הזוי בספטמבר. ממש מנסה ללמוד את זה לעומק.
איך זה? ואני חושבת שצריכים להעביר את העיתונאים שלנו לעבודה.
אז כאילו, מה בעצם? מה אני מחפשת? כאילו כן, איך זה יכול להיטיב איתך?
אל תעשה את זה, הרי שזה מושלם להתחיל להבין מה זה, אבל מבחינת השכר בתחום הזה אני בעיקרון כמי שכבר.
במקביל עד כמה שאפשר במילואים ואחרי זה גם כמה שנים אחורה.
בכל זאת, זה למרות הפציעה הקשה, מערכת העצבים.
הידיעה שלך הייתה יותר נוחה. אולי לשבת שם שלא ידעתי אם זה מבחינתי זה כמו.
השימוש מוסקוביץ. מחקר של הישראלי.
אבל שם זה זה הפרויקט לא שלו.
אז המבחן למבחן זה בשיטות של אני אצא עכשיו.
אה, כאילו בגלל זה זה כאילו ייתן לי עבודה נורא גדולה ואני צריכה להפגיש אותה ואני צריכה להיות כמה שיותר.
חייבת את זה בסוף להיות כל כך טוב ולא להעזר בהם.
כנראה גם אני כן. אבל זה באמת חוצפה עצומה.
של. עושה את המאמצים בלמידה למבחן.
אני כבר משקיעה בדרך למטרה, אבל גם בקשר לרוח החומר.
ואז לקראת המבחן, לפי מה שראיתי אפשר למקסם את עצמי וללמוד את עבודת השם.
כן, אני חושבת שזה. שבוע.
גם כן כמו שאת אומרת, זה די קשה לאתר פרויקט יפה.
גברים נעזרים במידה מלאכותית וזה גם הגיוני.
זה לא פתרון, אבל היא כן עושה את זה כל הזמן.
קשה לי לקבל אינדיקציה. תשמע, זה גם מנת זיכרון.
אני לא אשקר וגם כאילו לא יודעת. אולי יש דרך.
כאילו נראה לי שאם אני עושה פרויקט אז זה יהיה פרויקט שעכשיו צריכים לעשות איזשהו שם.
אבל זה לא כאילו אני לא חושב שיש. אף פעם לא עשיתי את זה.
אבל תגידי, אבל אם את סומכת מעבר לזה, בזמן שמתאים לך לא אז, היא אומרת, אז זה גם יכול להיות פתרון ריאלי.
כבר ניסיתי להבין איך זה עובד, כי אף פעם לא עשיתי בחירה במשרד זה.
או שזה כאילו זה שעה ושעה שמדברים על את של הקורס כאילו לא אמרו לנו אף.
כן, זה לאו דווקא נגיעה של אמריקה בצורה מטורפת.
זה נראה כאילו זה יכול להיות משהו קצת יותר קליל, אבל כן, ממש צ'ק ליסט.
כן, אבל גם שם נדבר בקרוב. אנחנו עוברים על כל הבחירה הקשה.
כן כן. אז כאילו אני אמורה לעשות לעבור על התפילין.
היום אני כבר קצת יותר משוחרר וזה.
בגדול כן. במהלך השאלות.
זאת אומרת מן הסתם השאלות שאולי הכי מאתגרות לא ניתן לשאול.
מה שכן נשמע סביר, אז זה גם סך הכל זה משהו אדפטיבי כזה.
שואלים שאלות של אנשים, מבקשים דברים, לא עושים דברים שאנחנו מייצרים, צריך לקנות.
אז אתה אומר אז כבר עוברים הלאה. עוד לפני.
איך? במהלך הביקור בשנת 2009, טען כי לא השלים את הקשר עם.
באמצע אוגוסט. אני יכולה לכתוב לך. אבל בשבוע. ספציפי.
צרחות חשמליות, ילדים קטנים. אז בטח זה טוב.
אבל כל עוד הילדים לא, את יודעת, זה לא כנראה השבועיים האחרונים של אוגוסט או משהו אחר.
מקסים. אבל. ואם אני רוצה לספטמבר 2011 גם לפני כן אז אני?
אפשר רק לפתוח אותה. תודה רבה לך. אוקיי, נמשיך.
אז כפי שאמרנו, ההצצה הראשונה שלנו נראית גם נגדיר באופן פורמלי.
לגבי מתן ניקוד כן פונקציית ניקוד לעצים, פרסים אפשריים מעל גרף הצלעות האפשריות זה בעצם גישת MSC.
כן, עוד גישה שמגדירה את המשקל של עץ. או את האיכות של עץ.
כסכום משקלי הצלעות שנמצאות בתוך העץ.
לגישה הזאת, דבר ראשון יש יתרון אחד ברור ושהיא שיטה שהאינפורמציה שאנחנו מבצעים עליה הוא טקסט כן או פתיר.
אז אמנם אתם למדתם אם אני לא טועה בפייסבוק data structure שאני חושב על MUST.
מקסימום על ספינינג שיבוא. רצים לא מכוונים נכון, אבל בעצם גם יש לזה גרסה של עצים מכוונים.
זה משהו שידוע כבר שנים רבות. אלגוריתם קלאסי.
גם בתרגיל אתם תראו אותו נקרא על שם ג'ול לו אדמונדס.
כן, זה שלושת האנשים שפיתחו אותו לא ביחד.
אולי שניים מהם היו ביחד, אבל כל פנים, זה היה, אני חושב שני מאמצים נפרדים.
לפחות על כל פנים, יש דרך לעשות את זה שזה כבר טוב עסק, אז אנחנו יכולים לעשות באמצעות ה msc Partner בהנחה באמצעות ה MSC.
אלגוריתם בהנחה שנדע לייצר את הגרף המלא של הצלעות האפשריות, אולי חלקכם תוהים מה לגבי label כן מלא?
מה קורה אם אנחנו רוצים לתת label three ולא try אז זה לא משנה את הדברים בצורה דרמטית.
אם אנחנו רוצים לתת לייבל Try, מה שאנחנו בעצם צריכים לעשות זה גרף הצלעות האפשריות.
עכשיו נהיה קצת יותר עשיר. בעצם הוא נהיה מולטי גרף, מה שנקרא.
נכון, יש בעצם הרבה צלעות אפשריות בכיוון מסוים בין זוג קודקודים.
נכון? אז יהיה לנו צלע השור למרי או ג'קט שומרי סף, ג'קט שומרי הדטרמיננטה שומרי מאוד יפה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז עדיין נצטרך למצוא מקסימום ספינים.
אגב, זה גם לא מסבך את הבעיה אלגוריתמית כן של מקסימום הספינים.
טריקי מה זה למצוא מקסימום ספינים במולטי גרף.
כן, בדיוק זה בעצם.
זה קודם לקחת את כל התשואות האפשריות בין זוג קודקודים בכיוון מסוים, למצוא מהם את הצלע הכי טובה שהולכת בין שני הקודקודים האלה בכיוון הזה, נכון?
ואז לעשות מקסימום פלנטרי על הגרף שקיבלנו?
כן, כי בטוח שאם יש, שאם הצלע לא יודע מה למרי קיימת, אוקיי, קיימת אולי אולי היא לא קיימת?
כן, אבל אם היא קיימת במקסימום ספינים אז היא תהיה זאת עם הלייבל הסביר ביותר בין שתי הצלעות האלה.
כן, על משכורת הגבוה ביותר, נכון? אז כאילו אפשר בעצם לפתור את הבעיות האלה בשני מעברים צר.
זה לא מסובך לחזור על זה, או שזה היה ברור?
אפשר לחזור על זה עוד פעם. נראה שזה לא היה כל כך ברור. אוקיי, אז מה קורה אם יש לכם מקסימום פנים tree אתם יש לכם פה נגיד במקרה שלנו.
ג'ון. מארי.
הצלעות האפשריות, אם זה זה זה זה רות.
וגם זה. וזה וזה.
וגם. זה וזה.
ו. פיספסתי משהו?
תקווה לא? בסדר, אז אלה כל האפשרויות.
עכשיו בואו נגיד שאתם בלייבל דברים נכון? אם אתם בלייבל דברים אז בעצם עכשיו יש כמה צבעים של צרות נכון בין כל זוג קודקודים.
שעשויה להיות ביניהם צהוב. נכון, יש צלעות סגולות ויש צלעות לבנות ויש צלעות.
כן חומות וירוקות.
וכן הבנתם את הרעיון. וכן וכנל לגבי כל אחת מהצורות האחרות.
כן? היה לי פה.
טוב. איפה הסקוואט? כן.
וכן הלאה. כן, אז יש שלוש תוצאות אפשריות עכשיו בין כל זוג קודקודים וכיוון.
אז איך אני עכשיו מוציא את המקסימום? אז אם היו לי את משקלי הצלעות?
כן? אז בעצם אם יש לי אלגוריתם שיודע למצוא מקסימום, אז Padding בגרף לא במולטי גרף נכון?
אז מה שאני עושה זה אני. קודם בוחר איזה מבין שלושת אלה היא הכי גבוהה, נגיד הסגולה ואיזה מבין שלושת אלה הכי גבוהה, נגיד החומה וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
נכון? ועכשיו קיבלתי גרף לא מולטי גרף כבר ועליו אני עושה מקסימום Speaking בסדר.
כי ברור שאם עם הצלע הזאת כן מי ידע?
הנה עם הסגולה יותר טובה מהחומר, אז זה אומר שבמציאות Sprint שהיא בטוח לא תופיע חומה.
אולי אני צריך להריץ את הצד שהוא לא Advanced כדי לדעת אם הסגולה תופיע כי אולי גם היא לא תופיע, אבל בטח שהחומה לא תופיע.
כן כי אני יכול להחליף אותה. פשוט הסגולה ורק לשפר.
כן, אני עובדת על הדברים.
באמת שלא צריך להיות. אז יכול להיות שיש לנו. עבור צילום צלע אחת יותר צריך משהו מאוד מאוד הגיוני.
אבל אם זה העיר בשליטתנו, אז הצלע השנייה כבר לא באמת יכולה להצביע על זה, לא?
אה, אוקיי, אז מה שאת אומרת זה מצוין, אבל תשימי לב שברגע שזה בדיוק מתקשר לנקודה שאמרתי קודם לגבי זה שיש כל מיני דרכים לתת ניקוד לעצים, פרסים אפשריים.
אבל אם את מחליטה ללכת, הפורמולה ציה של ה MSC שמייד נגדיר אותה פורמלית,
אבל בגדול זה פשוט הפורמולה זו שאומרת איכות של עץ או score של עץ או כסכום משקלי הצלעות.
אז בעצם. פשוט סוחבת את משקלי הצלעות.
כן, אין לך שום תלות כזאת. כן כן.
אוקיי, כן, אני עוד נכון מעט להתייחס לשאלה מה המגבלות של MSC.
אני מבין שאתם כבר מתחילים לחוש אותם, אבל עדיין אתה עדיין לא.
אוקיי, אז מה זה פורמלית? פורמלית, זה אמור להיראות לכם די מוכר.
אז זה הגרסה Label? אז בעצם אנחנו רוצים להגדיר score function.
כן, שיכולה לתת ציון לעץ פורס מכוון אפשרי על איזשהו אוסף קודקודים נתון דאבליו אחד דבליו דבליו אחד עד אין ורוט אימרות נאות במיוחד.
אנחנו. מה שאנחנו עושים זה בעצם מגדירים איזשהו פיצ'ר function C שהיא נותנת פיצ'רים, היא נותנת איזשהו וקטור פיצ'רים שכאן כתבתי אותו.
וקטור בינארי כן וקטור עם ערכים בינאריים, אבל זה גם יכול להיות ערכים ממשיים.
פשוט כרגיל. בדרך כלל עובדים בין מקטעים. פיצ'רים בינאריים שבעצם נותנת לכל צלע אפשרית.
לכל צלע אפשרית היא נותנת במשפט נתון היא מקבלת משפט,
היא מקבלת זוג קודקודים שאפשר שתהיה בינהם צלע והיא מקבלת לייבל והיא נותנת את אותו פיצ'ר וקטור של אפסים ואחדים.
ואז אני מגדיר בעצם את הפרמטרים של המודל הזה.
פרמטרים שהם טטה זה איזשהו Rate, וקטור וקטור משקולות.
אוקיי, ואז score של צלע פשוט מתקבלת כמכפלה סקלרית בין אותו Fetch, בין אותו וקטור משקולות.
אוקיי, שאומר עד כמה תכנית מסויימת היא אינדוקטיבית או קונטרה אינדוקטיבית לקיומה של צלע נכון?
אז כנראה דיסטנס גדול. מי לא יודע?
שלושת רבעי מאורך המשפט זה משהו קונטרה אינדיקציה TV לקיום צלע, אבל צלע שמחברת בין Patients,
בין Operation לדוקטור הזה או משהו כזה, זה משהו שהוא כן אינדיקציה לקיום מוצה למה שראינו בהתחלה.
אז בקיצור, כל מיני פיצ'רים שונים ומשונים תת משקל את אותם ואז אם אני,
אם אני רוצה לראות מה המשקל של עץ אפשרי זה בדיוק מתאים לפורמולה הציר של ה MSC פרסים כן,
או שה MC אופטימי זה ישן אז score של עץ אפשרי T עבור משפט זה פשוט.
כן, זה פשוט הפיצ'ר זה פשוט סכום משקלי הצלעות על אותו העץ.
כן, סכום משקלי הצלעות שנכנסות לאותו העץ שכל אחת מהם היא count.
זכרו מכפלה סקלרית של waves וכ'ו.
אוקיי, אז שאלות לגבי ההגדרה הזאת של המודל.
זה ברור. אוקיי, אז יפה, אז זאת ההגדרה של המודל.
אז מה זה בעצם אומר? כן, אז בוא נחזור לגרף שלנו.
מה זה בעצם אומר? זה שאנחנו מגדירים איזושהי פונקציה הפונקציה הזאת נותנת וקטורים שבעצם אפשר לחשוב עליהם או וקטורים של אפסים ואחד איפה הם חושבים עליהם?
פשוט כרשימה של תכוניות שהם אחד וכל השאר זה אפס באופן שקול.
אז נגיד אומרים אוקיי, אז אני מסתכל עכשיו על הצלע בין ג'ון למירי.
מסתכל על הפונקציות התכנוניות שלי, הפונקציות התכנוניות שלי, אומרת שנדלן נדלק.
כן, הפיצ'ר שאומר שהפרת Speech של מילת הגרעין המיועדת הוא נאום, נגיד אוקיי, והפרדה סופית של מילת העמודה First המיועדת.
כן. כלומר, הקודקוד שאליו נכנסת הצלע הוא גם גם נגיד ושם מילת גרעין עצמה.
ג'ון ושם מילת מרדיפה על עצמה עם מרי ושיש ביניהם פועל בין ג'ון נמרי שאנחנו עכשיו מנסים לחבר שהמרחק של הצלע 12,
שהכיוון שלה הוא ימינה, כלומר משמאל לימין.
ואולי גם פיצ'רים שקשורים בלמה כן. ובהמשך לשאלה שנשאלתי קודם.
וכל מיני דברים תכף מתאר אותם בצורה קצת יותר סיסטמטית.
כל מיני תכוניות כאלה נלך, נכפיל אותם, נכפיל את כל פיצ'ר שנדלק במה במשכורת שלה.
נכון, בשאיפה. למדנו משהו ונקבל בדיוק את הגרף שדיברנו קודם של גרף או מולטי גרף.
אם זה And אם זה לייבל ועליו נוכל להריץ את המקסימום.
Direct speaking try כאמור עם אלגוריתם כשהוא לא.
אז אוקיי, אז זה נהדר. זה מחסל לנו בעצם שניים מתוך שלושת הדברים שאנחנו צריכים כדי להגדיר אלגוריתם אפקטיבי הסתברותי, נכון?
מה הם היו שלושת הדברים להגדיר מודל כן, כלומר איך אנחנו נותנים score כן או הסתברות או לא משנה.
במקרה שלנו זה score ל היפותזה אפשרית רק לעץ אפשרי.
במקרה שלנו הגדרנו. זה מה שכתבנו קודם. נכון, אנחנו צריכים להגדיר עסק, איך בהינתן משפט חדש אנחנו מבצעים עסק, כלומר מוצאים את הלייבל הסביר ביותר במקרה.
כאן גם זה אמרנו נכון, לוקחים, בונים את הגרף הזה של כל הצלעות האפשריות, כי הקודקודים שלו זה את זה.
הטורקמנים מייצרים את הווקטור, פיצ'רים וכל אחת מהצלעות האפשריות מכפילים את הווקטור פיצ'רים הזה ב weight וקטור
מקבלים איזשהו מספר ואז מריצים אלגוריתם צ'ולו אדמונדס כדי לבחור את עץ הפריסה.
אז אוקיי, אז גם זה כיסינו וחסרה לנו רק הקומפוננטה השלישית והיא למידה.
נכון שבמקרה שלנו מה זה אומר למידה? מה אנחנו? מה הם הפרמטרים של המודל?
המשקולות בדיוק את המשקולות, את העבודה ולרוב לא משנה איך אתם אוהבים לקרוא אז כן, האמת שכדאי שאני אהיה עקבי.
אני לא שלכם כזה. אוקיי, אז אני אשנה את זה אחרי זה, את הכל טטה רק כדי להיות עקבי.
אז אוקיי, אז מה שאנחנו עשינו בעבר, שאלנו.
Score function נכון? ורצינו להפוך אותה בעצם לבצע למידה.
מה עשינו? הרבה פעמים אמרנו נגדיר אלגוריתם.
נגדיר בעצם לא גליל נייר מודל שמבוסס על ה score הזה נכון ונעשה מקסימום לייק להיות מיישם כדי למצוא את התא.
סביר ביותר לחשב את הגרדיאנט, כנראה כי כי אין בעיות לוג לינאריות.
כן, מודלים לא בלי נעליים אין צורה סגורה לה, אין לה מקסימום אז אבל מחשב את הגרדיאנט ונבצע איזשהו סטוקס יקרא לי את הסרט או משהו כזה.
אוקיי, אז אפשר גם ללכת באותו הכיוון. כאן אנחנו לוקחים משפט.
אנחנו רוצים לבנות מודל, מסכם נתיבי, לא גלינארי שמבוסס עליו.
למה לא? כן? אז יש לנו את ה score function.
כן שכתוב פה לפניכם. נכון עבור את T נתון כן לא כתבתי פה את לא את נתתי פה בכל מקום על המשפט,
אבל כמובן שתמיד הכוונה היא שיש איזה שהוא משפט נתון ברקע, סתם כדי לא לסבך את הנוסחאות.
ואז מה שאני עושה זה עבור כל עץ אפשרי. אני נותן לו score שהוא סכום משקלי הצלעות על weight וקטור כפול feature function.
זוכרים את זה על כל הצלעות בעץ מעלה את זה. האקספוננט מחשב את הסכום?
כן את הזה שהוא בעצם הסכום על כל האקספוננט,
ים של משקלי העצים האפשריים ומקבל מידת הסתברות על העצים שעכשיו אני יכול לגזור אותם ועל איך אני יודע איך נראה גרדיאנט של לוג לנייר מודל נכון?
כן עשינו את זה כבר כמה פעמים. זה פשוט הגרדיאנט.
נראה כן סכימה על כל הדוגמאות וכל פעם אנחנו בעצם צריכים לסכום על הצלעות בעץ הנכון, נכון?
ב. בעצם על הפיצ'ר Function על הצלעות הנכונות ולהוריד מזה את התוחלת של.
על פי התת הנוכחי כן, על פי ההסתברויות מושרות על העצים האפשריים, על פי הניחוש הנוכחי לתת.
אז התוחלת של הפיצ'ר Function של סכום הפיצ'ר Function על כל העץ וזה מסתבר כיוון ולידי ויש מעט עבודות שהולכים בדרך הזאת.
כמובן שהבעיה כרגיל בכן בגישה הזאת עימה.
מה פה? לא דיברתי עליו שהוא עשוי להיות מוקש בזה.
כן נכון, זמן ריצה מכבד פה לחשב.
אני יכול לעשות את הגרדיאנט. מה מתוך הגרדיאנט? קשה לחשב.
איזה ביטוי נכון בדיוק? התוחלת על פני כל העצים האפשריים זה לפחות באופן נאיבי לסכום על כל העצים האפשריים.
כל אחד מהם נחשב לא את ההסתברות לחשב את הפיצ'ר Function עליו ולסחוב את הכל ביחד.
נכון, זה כבד. לפחות באופן נאיבי אמרנו יש מספר אקספוננציאלי של עצים.
מסתבר שאם עובדים מספיק קשה ומי שמתעניין יכול לקרוא את המאמר של טריקו ואחרים מ 2007,
אז אם עובדים מספיק קשה, אפשר לקחת את התוחלת הזאת ולהציג אותה בצורה אחרת, כך שזה כן יהיה צ'ק Table.
כן, ולבצע את החישוב הזה זה לא שיטה מאוד פופולרית אבל היא קיימת.
אני במקום זה אציג לכם גישה אחרת שהיא מאוד נפוצה ולמעשה היא נפוצה לא רק בהקשר הזה,
אלא היא נפוצה בהרבה הקשרים של סקטור פרטי, ולכן חשוב לי לדבר עליה בגדול.
זה מה שנקרא עבד פוסטר כן או האבה Structure פרוסה כאן קוראים לו שהוא אלגוריתם סך הכל מאוד פשוט, אבל מסתבר שגם ואפקטיבי כן.
אז מי שמתעניין בלקרוא על האלגוריתם הזה כולל תיאוריה שמאחוריו כמה משפטים מתמטיים שאפשר להוכיח על ההתכנסות שלו.
אז אתם מוזמנים לקרוא את המאמר הזה של מייקל קולינס מ 2002.
מי שלא אני אתן לכם את התקציר. תקציר האירועים בגדול, מה שצריך לעשות במקרה הזה זה זה.
במקום לחשב את הגרדיאנט מחליפים את התוחלת פה.
כן. אז במקום בעצם לחשב את הגרדיאנט או את סטוקס גרדיאנט כן, את בעצם את הביטוי כאן לוקחים את התוחלת הזאת ומחליפים אותה במקסימום.
אוקיי. בעצם, במורד של ההתפלגות הזאת בא השכיח של ההתפלגות הזאת ולוקחים את העץ במקור התוחלת.
אזי כל העצים לוקחים את העץ הסביר ביותר תחת הניחוש הנוכחי שלי לתא.
אוקיי, מחשבים עליו את הפיצ'ר Function בסדר עבור העץ היחיד הזה, האחד הטוב ביותר על פי התת שיש לי.
ואז מסתכלים על החיסור בין שני הפיצ'ר Function זה אוקיי, נשמע כמו רעיון.
אולי קצת משונה, אבל בעצם מי שכאן מכיר. יצא לכם להכיר את האלגוריתם הפרסי פה?
לא? אוקיי? באיזה הקשר ראית אותו? הבעיה אם אין לכם את זה אז אה, מאוד נכנסים לזה.
לא נכנסים לזה. אוקיי, מי שמכיר את האלגוריתם הפרסי פתרון זה בעצם ככה הוא.
ככה הוא עובד רק שם. בדרך כלל מציגים אותו לא למקרה structure באמת וזהו, אלא מציגים אותו עבור גרסה של קלסי פיקציה בינארית בדרך כלל.
אבל קולינס בדיוק הרחיב את התיאוריה כדי שתכסה גם את המקרה.
Capture ובגדול. זה נחמד מאוד, כי אומנם מחשב תוחלת על פני מספר אקספוננציאלי של אפשרויות,
זה משהו שצריך לעבוד קצת קשה כדי להבין איך עושים אותו בצורה וקצבי להתקיים בצורה יעילה,
אבל למצוא את את האופטימים תחת התת הנוכחי, כלומר את העץ, שמן הקסם, סליחה, את העץ, כן, את העץ הסביר ביותר תחת התת תחת התת הנוכחית זה משהו הרבה יותר קל.
אז מהו העץ הסביר ביותר? בוא ניזכר מהי מהו, מהי הסבירות של עץ?
כן, סבירות של עץ היא פשוט האקספוננט של הספור שלו.
חלקי גורם נירמול נכון. לכן מהו העץ הסביר ביותר?
המשקה הכי גדול זה אם המשקה הכי גדול. נכון, זה עם השקר הכי גדול.
ואיך קראנו לעץ עם אזכור הכי גדול? כאשר הסכום מוגדר כסכום על פני כל הצלעות של משקלי הצלעות.
כן, בדיוק קראנו לזה מקסימוס פלנטרי, אז זה דבר מאוד נחמד, נכון?
כי זה אנחנו כבר יודעים לעשות. אנחנו כבר יודעים לעשות כן.
יש את אותו אלגוריתם אינפרה אדום. במילים אחרות מה שעשה ציר כבר ספקטרום, וזו הסיבה שכל כך אוהבים אותו.
הוא אומר לנו משהו מאוד נחמד, הוא אומר. אם שברתם את הראש והבנתם איך לעשות Influence יעיל למשימת הסקר באודישן, משימה שהיא לא בהכרח קלה.
תלוי בסטיק. כן, במקרה שלנו במקרה יש אלגוריתם קלאסי שעושה את זה.
כן, אבל אם הצלחתם לעשות את זה, אז הנה אני אציע לכם אלגוריתם למידה שלא מצריך כמעט שום דבר מעבר לגור איתם.
העסק תיקחו, תפסו כמה איטרציות Scanner של איזשהו היפר פרמטר, תעברו על כל הדוגמאות או הדגמות, דוגמה בסדר או משהו כזה.
כן, נגיד תעברו על כל הדוגמאות. סיקוונס ריאלי זה לא כזה משנה.
בדרך כלל עושים להם איזשהו פאנטום שאפל. הם ימצאו את העץ הטוב ביותר תחת score function הנוכחי שלכם.
כן, כלומר תחת התת הנוכחי שלכם. אתם כמובן מתחילים איזשהו ניחוש לתת נגיד כל אפסים או משהו רנדומלי, אבל לא יודע מה תמצאו את העץ הסביר ביותר.
זה פשוט תריצו את אלגוריתם העסק שלכם. תעדכנו את טטה ככה שתוסיפו לו איזשהו learning rate כפול.
ההפרש בין הפיצ'ר function. הסכום הפיצ'ר Function על פני הצלעות.
בגולדן סטנדרט Rate פחות הסכום הפיצ'ר Function על הצלעות בעץ הסביר ביותר ואז בסוף מה שגם קולינס
מראה שיש סיבות גם תיאורטיות לחשוב שזה רעיון טוב אבל גם טכנית זה מייצב את האופטימיזציה.
תחזירו את בדרך כלל מה שעושים זה מחזירים את הממוצע של הבטטות.
כן, זה מסתבר, נותן שערוך יותר יציב, בייחוד אם אתם מריצים את זה מספיק זמן.
כן, כמה איטרציות כן, כמה אפקטים על פני כל הדאטה.
אז אתם אתם בעצם בגלל שזה מין תהליך כזה אונליין?
כן, שאתם כל פעם לוקחים דוגמה אחת מזיזים לפיה, אז זה מייצב את האלגוריתם שאתם מחזירים את הממוצע.
שרטט את שעברתם בדרך ולא רק את הטאץ הסופי שהגעתם עד אז.
זה השורה מספר 6. עכשיו זה גם יש לה פרשנות אינטואיטיבית.
סך הכל נכון. מה שזה אומר זה שאם כבר הדת שלכם היא כזאת שבעצם עבור הדוגמה, אם כן, עבור הדוגמה שאתם מחזיקים ביד נותנת את Score הגבוה ביותר לעץ הנכון.
אז מה אתם צריכים לעשות עם טטה? כלום.
כלום. נכון, ההפרש שם הוא יהיה 0. איפה שם מקופלת?
אלרגיה לעור? מצעים, מצעים?
איזשהו חזה הוא כמעט. האם זה נכון? אבל יש צלע אחת הבדל.
יש צלע אחת שקיימת בגולן ולא קיימת בפרי קטן וצלע בקרדיט קטן שלא קיימת בגולן.
מה אז תעשו? מה בעצם ייצא הסכום פה?
לי. בדיוק. זה פשוט יהיה ההפרש בין הפיצ'ר Function לבין שההצעות.
כן, איזה מין כזה אתם יכולים לחשוב על זה? אינטואיטיבית כן. אוקיי, אז אני אקח את הצלע הזאת.
כן, נסתכל על כל הפיצ'רים של האיי, קח את הצלע הפוטנציאלית הזאת, הכל, כל הפיצ'רים האפשריים שלה.
איפה בכלל יש הבדל? נכון, כי אם הם, אם הם זהים אני לא רוצה אולי לשנות את השם נכון?
כי אין שום ערך. תסכים נתיבי בפיצ'ר הזה נכון?
הצלע הנכונה והלא נכונה יש לו בדיוק את אותו ערך, אבל במקומות שבהם הם שונים אני ארצה לעדכן את האתר.
אוקיי, אז כך שהוא יהיה יותר דומה לגולף, כאילו פחות דומה לזה.
אוקיי. בסדר, אז זה הרעיון.
זה הסוד של הסרטון והוא אלגוריתם שאפשר להפעיל אותו.
כפי שאתם מבינים לא רק על. על בעיות של עץ כן, אלא גם בעיות של פרדי קצין.
אני השתמשתי פה פעם באיזה מחקר על בעיות של לחזות גרף דו צדדי.
כן, עם איזשהו score function עליו ואנשים השתמשו בו כדי כן כדי כדי לחזות כל מיני סוגים של מבנים קומבינטורים.
כל עוד יש לכם Influence יעיל או מה שמסתבר גם וזה לא ניכנס לזה כאן.
אבל אפילו אם יש לכם Influence לא מדוייק, אבל שהוא פחות או יותר מדוייק כן, ויש גם לזה איזשהי הגדרה.
מה זה אומר פחות או יותר מדויק? אז זה אלגוריתם מספיק רובה סטטי כדי שאז בכל זאת זה יתן לכם בדרך כלל תוצאות טובות.
זאת אומרת זה אלגוריתם מאוד חזק, מאוד פשוט ומאוד חזק.
שווה לזכור זה שאלות לגבי זה. אוקיי, בסדר.
ועכשיו השאלה היא מה? אוקיי, אז סיפרנו, אז הצגנו את הכל.
יש לנו אלגוריתם למידה שלנו עבור איתם עסק. יש לנו את המודל כמובן.
עכשיו השאלה היא איזה פיצ'רים אנחנו רוצים להכניס. הפיצ'ר Function בגדול.
כל פיצ'ר של הרומנטים של הפיצ'ר Function מקבל הוא בסדר, אבל פיצ'רים שנגיד לפחות השתמשו בהם במאמר המקורי כוללים באמת את הזהות של המילים.
זה תופס את כל מה שקראנו ביי ביי לפסיקה לפין אייטיז.
נכון? כאילו הקשר אני אזכיר לכם. נכון את זה שנגיד Patients וסכרת אז זה לא משהו.
אולי מאוד סביר. טוב, במקרה כאן זה גם מתווך דרך ווינט אבל נגיד ודוקטור זקן.
אבל אבל אולי לא יודע.
כן אמרנו Patients בפיזור אולי זה גם מתאים וכן הלאה.
אבל צלעות אחרות פחות. זה מתאים עם משהו שהוא הוא מתאים כדי פנדל של.
כנוהל ידיים מתאים כדי פנדל של נאון, אבל לא, או של תואר, אבל לא מתאים כדי פנדיט של וכן הלאה וכן הלאה.
אוקיי, אז אפשר להסתכל על Bill פסק אלפינית אייטיז.
אפשר להסתכל על ה part of speech שלהם.
כן, פרד speech זה דבר טוב להסתכל עליו בנוסף למילים כי א פעם זה עושה DSM מאסיה.
נכון הפרוטו Speech עם המילה בכל זאת אדבר בועדת תבונה או כל דבר אחר שהוא יכול להיות, וגם מהבחינה שזה מוריד את אספאס.
נכון, זה פיצ'רים הרבה פחות. ספארס יש רק כך וכך כמה עשרות ספיץ אפשריים.
מילים יש הרבה ובוודאי אם מסתכלים על זוגות מילים אז יש כמספר מילים בריבוע.
כן, מאוד. ספארס ככלל. הרבה פעמים מקדונלד השתמש גם בפרט speak שהמילים שנמצאות בין Wi ודאבל ג'יי בין שתי המילים שהוא מסתכל עליהם,
ולא רק בין אלא גם משמאל מימין, כלומר מחוץ לספרד, ביניהם גם זה, מסתבר, נתן לו רמזים.
כן, אז נגיד סו ג'ונסון, מרי מגווייר, Yesterday with his טלסקופ.
אז אולי את זה שמופיע אחרי Will score נגיד, ניתן לנו רמז שאיזו צלע היא סבירה.
אוקיי, יש לכם את המשפט ג'ונסון מקווה אם יש לו דיוויזית טלסקופ.
כן. ונגיד שאתם יודעים שאחרי ווייז מגיע אז טלסקופ בסדר, אז זה על פניו יגדיל אולי את הסיכוי שהוא יזוז מחובר לזה לשיא או לסוף במקרה כזה נכון?
אז דברים כאלה? כן.
אז עוד דבר שהוא השתמש בו מרחק של צלעות שדיברנו עליו הכיוון של צלעות.
אז מסתבר שבהרבה שפות.
בהרבה שפות. כיוון של הצלע, בטח אם אנחנו גם יודעים, הלייבל של הצלע הוא מאוד אינדיקטור.
ביבי נכון, למשל בעברית פערים יופיעו מאיזה צד של השם עצם שאליו הם מתייחסים בדרך כלל אחרי.
נכון כאילו. טוב, השאלה אם זה מימין או שמאל. תלוי איך אתם כותבים את זה אבל עם אינדקס יותר גבוה נכון?
באנגלית זה יהיה ההפך. אוקיי, אז כל הדברים האלה אפשר ללמוד עם הפיצ'רים מהסוג הזה.
גם כמובן הלייבל Features וכל מיני קומבינציות של הפיצ'רים האלה.
אז כמובן בגלל שהמשכורות הם לינאריות כאן הרבה פעמים שווה לנו לקחת פיצ'ר שאומר הפרק speech של הגרעין הוא non וגם יש לידו וי.
הלייבל הוא איקס ויש לידו מילה מפרטי Speech שזה אוקיי או כל מיני דברים כאלה.
איך בדיוק עושים את זה? מי שמתעניין יכול לקרוא במאמר הזה.
יש לזה מאז גם הרבה מים זרמו בנהר.
זה קצת השתנה, אבל הרעיונות על רעיונות דומים כן. אני לא זוכרת איך כשיש לנו משפט חדש, איך אנחנו מבצעים את זה?
אה, אוקיי, אז תשימי לב שכל הדברים האלה שדיברנו עליהם עד עכשיו הם בעצם דברים שמותר לנו להתנות עליהם.
כן, כי כי זה או פיצ'רים. זאת אומרת, בעצם על מה מותר לך?
מה מותר לך שהפיצול פעם שנייה תלוי במינים עצמם או בכל פריט Processing שעשית עליהם?
נגיד, אם אנחנו מדברים על of speech takes או למה, אז כאילו זה מניח שהם זמינים לך בקורפוס כי הוא כבר תויג בזה,
או שעשית איזה שהוא שלב מקדים של תיוג שאת מספיק סומכת עליו כדי לקודד אותו בפיצ'רים.
זה יכול להשתמש בלייבל נכון בגלל שכל צלע אפשרית יש לה גם לייבל נקוב, אם זה לייבל פרטי Speech לייבל Department שפרסם וזה יכול להשתמש במשפט עצמו.
כן, באיזה מילים מופיעות במשפט פשוט, בין אם מימין לשמאל, באמצע המילים כן בחינם כן.
והכיוון של הצללה כמובן גם נכנס לתוך זה, כי בעצם נקבע על פי המשפט אם זה ימין או ימינה או שמאלה ומה האורך של הצל ודברים כאלה.
אז כל הדברים האלה את יכולה להשתמש בהם. מותר לך?
את יודעת לבנות איזה אוסף פיצ'רים שאת רוצה שמבוסס עליהם, כאילו בעצם יש לנו פה גם את הלייבל שאתה רוצה להוסיף, ויש לך גם ערך שאנחנו חוזים.
בהינתן שמצאנו את הערך, אז אני מדברת על ההבדל בין לייבל לבין Party speech בעצם, או בין מה למה?
גם כן אני מנסה להבין. אוקיי, אז בוא נחזור שנייה לעניין שכבר יש לנו מוצרים נוספים.
אז תראי. השאלה איזה מידע יש לך בפרי Processing?
זה תלוי פשוט באיזה פריט Processing עשית.
אבל צודקת. אולי הייתי צריך להקדים ולומר שבדרך כלל לפני שמתחילים בכלל לפני שאת מריצה את הפרק הזה,
למרות שאני אומר בדרך כלל כי לכל דבר יש זה, אבל בטח הצורה שאנחנו שאני מלמדת זה פה בקורס, ואני באמת אוסיף את זה בצורה מפורשת.
זה נקודה טובה. זה שאנחנו מניחים שהמשפט כבר עבר כניסת ציה, כלומר מחולק לחתיכות, בעצם אנחנו כבר יודעים מי הם הקודקודים.
עשינו להם למוטיבציה. כן, כמו שראינו קודם בעברית עם הדוגמה הזאת, עם הכתובת הארמנית ועשינו מפתח ספיץ תגיד שהוא אולי קצת, או שהוא נתון או שעשינו את זה.
כן, אז כאילו שאולי הוא כל דבר. כל דבר מהדברים האלה עשוי להיות רועש.
כן, עקרונית כן, כי אם עשינו אותם אוטומטית והם לא פשוט Gold standard ואנחנו כרגע מתעלמים מזה.
זאת אומרת, אנחנו מתעלמים מכרתים כבודנו.
אז כי אנחנו מומחים של תהליכים מספיק אמינים לצרכן, או לפחות משמעותית יותר אמינים מאשר הדיפנדר Parts שאנחנו הולכים להריץ.
כך שכן הכמות של הרעש איכשהו תיבלע.
כן. ואז אין פה איזשהו סוג של ספינות.
זה בסדר. עצמאות זה מה שמעניין באמת להוציא.
אבל אם אתה מוציא שם כמעט על האיברים שלהם במקרה של המוזיקה, אז כן, הלייבלים הם חלק מהעץ.
כן הם חלק מהארץ. אז נגיד ההוצאות על האימונים שלא תואמים להעברת התפקיד של שחר.
עקרונית כן נכון, עקרונית כן. אז הנה אז ככה, כן, אולי את יודעת מה?
אולי אני אציג את זה קצת יותר ברור.
אתן לכם דוגמה איך זה נראה?
אוקיי, אז ככה זה יראה, נגיד בקורסים שאתם. תגיעו אליהם.
אז נגיד באנגלית. כן, רואים את זה מספיק טוב להגדיל את הפונט.
אוקיי, אז אוקיי,
בהתחלה זה סתם Comments שאומרות לך ניר איך נראה הטקסט של המשפט ומה ID שלו וכאלה בסדר הזה זה פשוט פקודה אז זה Comments ואחרי זה זה המשפט עצמו.
אז יש לך אינדקס לכל לכל תוכן.
אם זה בעברית כמו שראינו קודם, אז יש לך בעצם גם אינדקסים שאומרים לך מה כתוב ביחד, כאילו בלי רווח, כאילו עם פיצול ובלי פיצול.
אבל תכלס את יכולה גם לראות את זה פשוט מהטקסט עצמו שכתוב לך מעל המשפט אז ועכשיו יש לך פשוט זה הולך.
פורים פורים כן ישחטו. הראשון זה הבעיה כפי שהיא כתובה בטור השני.
זה עלמא שבאנגלית, כפי שאתם רואים, כמעט זהה בדרך כלל לזה.
חוץ מכאן זה הפך לכם, אבל זה כאילו מאוד זניח בעברית וערבית וכאלה שפות.
מטבע הדברים זה יותר משמעותי. יש את שפת Speech שלו.
יש לך את במקרה כאן כמו שני party speech אם אחד יותר קורס ואחד יותר פיינברג זה כבר תלוי ספציפית בסכמה.
אוקיי, אבל יש לך ייצוג של עמודה או שתי עמודות, או שבעצם ממפת Speech אחרי זה יש לך עוד כל מיני פיצ'רים מורפולוגיים.
גם זה שוב, זה תלוי בסכמה, אבל גם על זה פחות דיברנו. ואחרי זה יש לך בעצם את הדיפרנציאל structure שזה מה שאת רואה שם.
יש לך שלוש, זה אומר זה שאחד הוא דיפנדר 73 כן, זה בעצם לפי index.
אחת מהמילים במשפט תמיד יהיה לאינדקס של head שהוא אפס שהיא איזה מילה הרות, ובמקרה שלנו של from ba פיקס זה story כאן.
נכון? אתם רואים שם שזה אפס כתוב. זה קצת לא מיושר, כן?
ואחרי זה מגיע label keys בצרורות וכן הלאה.
אז באופן עקרוני יכול להיות עם הקלאסי שלך לא מספיק טוב שהוא יחצה צלע שהיא לא מתאימה לך.
אז כאילו אלה שני מימדים שונים. כן, אחד הוא חלק מהאן פוסט והשני הוא חלק מהאותיות.
אז עקרונית יכול להיות שכן, שתהיה איזושהי התאמה ביניהם.
עוד שאלות. בסדר.
טוב, אז זה בגדול. אז זה בגדול.
ההגדרה של MP4. כן אמרנו המודל, הלמידה, העסק influence ו הפיצ'רים.
אבל כפי שכבר חלק מכם מכם שמו לב, העמסתי פרסר.
כן הוא ההגדרה הזאת שבעצם משקל של עץ או איכות של עץ היא כ.
כסכום משקלי הצלעות שמשתתפות בו.
היא לא אופטימלית, כי למה היא לא אופטימלית?
בדיוק מהסיבות שכן שחלקכם העליתם כאן קודם.
כי לפעמים עצם זה שאני יודע שהצלע מסוימת קיימת בפרס או לא קיימת, עשויה להשפיע על כמה אני חושב שאצל האחרת היא סבירה או לא סבירה.
נכון? במילים אחרות, אם הייתי יודע מה פרט דיקציה אחת, זה היה לא רק משנה לי את העץ שהניח זה כי זה גם MUST.
פרס קורה נכון? אם אני יודע שהצלחת קיימת או לא משנה שתי צלעות קיימות אז אני יודע שאני לא יכול לסגור מעגל ביניהם.
נכון? כי פשוט עד שהוא לא אדמונדס כן MSC אלגוריתם לא יחזיר לי פשוט עץ כזה.
אז כבר קודם כבר באיזושהי פרסה יש תלות בין הצלעות, אבל התלות הזאת לא מתבטאת במשקולות.
נכון, המשקולות הם קבועים, הם ניתנו על בסיס הפיצ'ר Function שהוא עצמו לא קשור לעץ שאליו הצלע שייכת או לא שייכת, אבל לפעמים זה לא נכון.
אז בוא נסתכל שוב על המשפט ממקודם. פיט gain first gain אקוגני שמן זה קאובוי?
Hi מובי תלמה סיינט לואיס. אוקיי, אז במקרה כאן בהחלט אפשר.
בהחלט אפשר לטעון שיש קשר בין הצלעות.
כן, למשל אולי game כן to gain hyper.
כן, אותו gain איזשהו מושג עקיף או לא משנה, תיאור שהגרעין שלו הוא היטב, העיקר הוא בפני עצמו.
לא נשמע כמו דבר נורא סביר. כן, מה זה? מה זה בעברית?
להרוויח טרמפיסט אולי נשמע קצת מוזר.
כן, אבל לעומת זאת אם אני יודע שזה gain recognition, דבר ראשון לא סתם gain אלא gain וכו גמישים ושזה לא סתם Hacker אלא game אקוגני של איזה שהיא יקרה.
כלומר אני כבר יודע שהצלע אם כבר הייתי אומר לכם תשמעו הצלע הזאת קיימת.
Hi קר קשור לעז. כן וערכו גמיש אם קשור ל gang.
אוקיי אז רקוב מישן או דיפנדר סט של gain או מולטיפלייר של game ואז הוא מאוד יפה.
האירו פנטן של צ'יקה. אז הייתם אומרים טוב גיין רקוב מישן אז אי אפשר.
העיקר זה כבר איכשהו נשמע לי מתקבל על הדעת. כן, ואולי צוואות אחרות היו נשמעות לכם במקרה כזה פחות סבירות.
כן, גם לזה אנחנו תכף נראה גם לזה. אנחנו תכף נראה דוגמאות.
אז עצות בהחלט יכולות להשפיע אחת על השנייה, אבל MSC פרופר לא מסוגל בעצם לא מסוגל לקודד השפעות.
כן, כן, לא מסוגל לבטא את הקשר הזה בין הניקוד של צליל, בין הופעה או אי הופעה של צורות אחרות, פשוט מעצם הגדרתו.
לכן יש גישה שבעצם נקראת hair order features.
כן air אודר features שהיא אומרת אוקיי, המודל LST הוא נחמד, אבל הוא לא מספיק.
בוא ננסה להוסיף או לשכלל אותו עוד ואנחנו תכף נראה באיזה מחיר.
אז אוקיי, אז היי או הפיצ'ר זוהי רוברט פרשינג model.
זה בעצם כל הפסיק מאות. אז כל הגרף באס פרשינג מודלס שלו מתפרקות.
כן, שבהם הניקוד של עץ לא מתפרק על פני הצלעות כן או לא נקבע פשוט כסכום של של משקלים, של צלעות אינדיבידואליות, אלא על סטים של צלעות.
איזה סטים זה כבר תלוי בסט? אוקיי, בדרך כלל אנחנו לא מרשים לסקור Function להיות תלוי בקבוצה מכל סוג שהוא של צלעות.
זה פשוט יהפוך את הבעיה מאוד קשה, חישובית, מאוד כבדה חישובית לבצע Insurance, אלא אנחנו איכשהו מגבילים את זה.
אז נגיד למשל הגרנד Child model.
אוקיי, מודל הנכד אולי אפשר לקרוא לו בעברית אומר את הדבר הבא אומר יש לי בעצם score function score function הזה הוא בעצם הניקוד שאני נותן לעץ.
דבר ראשון הפונקציה של המשקלים של הצלעות הבודדות.
כן, במובן הזה הוא רק מרחיב את העמסתי פרסר. כן, זה גורם.
השני זה הגורם המוכר והאהוב MC פרסר שמסתכל על משקלי הצלעות.
כן על הקשרים, על איזה צלעות סבירות או לא סבירות. אבל יש פה גורם נוסף שהוא מסתכל על שלשות של קודקודים.
אוקיי, שבהם בעץ יש גם את הצלע איי.
ג'יי וגם את הצלע. ג'יי. קיי. אוקיי, אז בעצם אם יש לי איזשהו עץ, נגיד ג'ונסון Merge?
כן, בוא נשאיר את זה כרגע אן לייבל פשוט כדי שלא לגמרי זה יהפוך לקשקוש.
אמ. כן?
אז בעצם אם MSC פרסר אמר אוקיי, אני צריך מראש להגיד כמה כל צלע שבה באופן בלתי תלוי לעץ, היא תמיד תהיה שווה את הדבר הזה.
עכשיו תחליטו אם לקחת אותה או לא לקחת אותה. כן, זה המשחק עכשיו.
יש לי פה עוד גורם שאומר אם יש לי שתי צלעות שמהוות בעצם שרשרת.
כן, מסלול באורך שתיים, אני יכול להוסיף עוד גורם שתלוי.
זאת אומרת עוד גורם שבעצם הוא תלוי בקומבינציה שלהם.
אז נגיד למשל, אם הצלע הזאת יש לה משקל עשר ולזאת עשר סתם לזאת תשע.
שמונה ושבע או משהו.
אז עכשיו אם קודם לכל עץ בהם אס טי שמכיל את הצלע הזאת.
והזאת ירוויח מהם 19.
כן, כלומר אם הצלע הזאת קיימת בעץ או לא קיימת.
כן, הצלע הזאת שמסומנת כאן לא משפיע על האם הצלע הזאת תהיה יותר סבירה או פחות סבירה.
כן, מבחינת המשקל שלה. אבל גריינג'ר מודל אומר לו אתה תסחוב את ה 10 וה 9, אבל בוא נגיד שאני רוצה ללמוד כן,
כי נגדית מראה לי שאם הצלע הזאת נכנסת זאת הופכת להיות הרבה הרבה פחות סבירה.
אוקיי, די סבירה מראש, אבל ברגע שהכנסתי את זאת על הפנים, יורדת לכל אחד בסדר.
אז מה שהמודל הזה יעשה זה בעצם איך הוא. איך הוא יפתור את זה?
איך הוא יאפשר לנו לבטא את זה? כי עכשיו היא הופכת מ 9 ל 1.
אז נגיד, אני עדיין יכול להשאיר את זה 10 ואת זה 9,
אבל להוסיף עוד גורם שאם זה וזה נכנס אז אתם מקבלים מינוס שמונה נקודות בסדר ואז זה בעצם יהפוך להיות כאילו כאילו יחד.
בסדר, אז זה נותן לי כוח כוח נוסף.
למה אני ארצה בכלל כזה דבר? ובאיזה מקרים זה עוזר לי?
ואיך אני עוד יכול להרחיב את העניין? עשיתי מודל להראות אר Features.
את כל זה נגלה אחרי ההפסקה. שיעור המס פה.
למה זה לא השפיע על? עכשיו לא הכרטיס שלך קצת לארץ?
אז באמת. כן, עד לפני כמה זמן התמונה המפורסמת אם אנחנו צורכים אותה בעוצמה.
זה לא מאוד אמור לעניין אותי. בכל מקרה, לא חייבים להיכנס לפה בכוח, אבל לא של המילים הבודדות.
אבל אני רוצה הצנועות. בשנים מכן.
איך שזה נראה בעבר, שקופיות שמראים זה היה המילה של האבא של המילה, שזה נכון.
אה, לא, זה לא בהכרח. זה לא בהכרח כן.
בסדר, נגיד שמשלמים נגיד למשל סבא של סבא של סבא סבתא שלו זה יותר טוב.
אז זה לא קשור לעניין הזה. מי הבורסה ומי הם הסדרה המצליחה הזאתי?
מפרסמים את זה כאילו זה מין שלב נוסף.
בשביל זה צריך להשתנות. יש.
ללא שום קשר עברתי קורס ובמהלך במילואים.
כמו כן גם. את תהליך ברמאללה.
סרטו התיעודי. גם זה.
דרך אגב העובדה שאנחנו לא באגף של.
סתיו שפיר מבינה שיש אינטרס.
ואני לא יודעת למה זה להסתכל.
לא אחד לא הולך לגור בארץ.
מה שהיה. מבחוץ זה מה שאתה רוצה.
2002. חברת תשתיות התקשורת.
אני. חושב שהגיע.
הזמן שהילד שלנו יצא לשירות מזהיר בצהל.
מזכיר מקרה זה עושה שכיבות סמיכה. כן.
אני מתכננת כל סימסטר. רציתי להזכיר לעצמי שזה.
מזה ארבע שנים. בקשת הסליחה.
תומר סוויסה. החליט לעשות מעשה אחד ספציפי.
המוזיאון מזכיר את מאדוף. יש לעשות קורלציה של איכות.
איזה כיף! מנכל אפל סטיב ג'ובס.
זה ממש כיף היה לעזוב את הדירה בשבוע שעבר. נניח.
כן זה בסדר לעשות. כל ארבע שנים הוא.
זה צריך להיות שלכל דבר יש לך הסבר?
איך אתה מסביר? צפון קוריאה.
בשלב. זה.
שני הצדדים. לכן זה נשמע.
כאילו אנחנו מנסים לעשות משהו כמו שרק זה השקעה של.
זה של. אז.
עלילת הספר מתרחשת. איזה מזל.
אשמח. שאנחנו צריכים.
זהו סוג של שבירה של. כל ההשקעה הזה.
השאלה הזאת קלאסית. שהוא מקבל.
ואני יכול את. בעיה.
מסוג זה. בזמן שניסתה מספר.
פשוט. ממילא כיוון כמעט.
זה. לקחת.
אז לא הייתי מוצאת את עצמי חוששת להיות.
אז הוא אומר אתה רוצה עכשיו? 3. הרבה יותר זול מאשר.
סוג של עסקת טיעון שבה. אנחנו כל הזמן.
לא יכול להיות. למעשה אני צריכה להתחיל לעבוד בערך.
15 פעם בחודש. הסיבה פשוטה.
זה התחיל במהלך השנים. 1941, באמצע שנות ה 60 שהיה צריך לעשות שבעה שבעה אנשים בשבוע.
כל עוד לא הייתה.
חבר. בוועד המנהל של.
זה כל. כך לא נכון.
הפרופסור סיפר. ועדיין.
שהיה. עכשיו מעניין רוצה.
זה אחד מהמשחקים שלנו, אבל לא תמיד זה.
משחק. אף אחד לא רוצה לבזבז את הזמן, אבל לא רואה שום דבר פה בטוח.
אבל אמרתי שאני מפסיד. כל משחק פה אפילו לא קשור לזה.
זה פשוט מתחיל. כן. בסך.
משנת. אם אתה רוצה.
מסתבר שזה עובד. יועצו של שגריר.
ישראל לשעבר בארצות הברית, סטפן.
ואם המחשב הנייד. ראש.
מרכז. אז. זהו, שזה מה שהולך.
לא שמענו עליו יותר מדי.
כן כן, זה נראה כאילו גם היה איזה רעיון מטופש של 15.
הייתי שמח למצוא משהו אחר.
אז הקימו בעיר. יישוב קטן.
בשם. הרחקה חוזרים?
טוב. אז היינו בחירות Reflections.
ודיברנו ספציפית על מה שנקרא גריינג'ר מודל.
כן, מודל הנכד לפעמים נקרא גם הגראנד פרינט מודל מסיבות דומה.
כן, של איזה כיוון אתם מסתכלים על זה? למה שבכלל נרצה להשתמש בו?
אז בואו נסתכל על. כן.
אז בואו למשל נסתכל על המשפט הבא ג'ון hit the ball with the beat.
אוקיי, אז. לכאורה יכול להיות כן.
בסיס מבנה המשפט נכון מבחינת הפרט כספית שלו.
נגיד והמבנה התחבירי שלו. יכול בהחלט להיות שג'ון היכה בכדור בכדור שהיו לו מחבט או משהו כזה או היה לו עטלף.
נגיד הכדור עם העטלף, נגיד, אולי זה יכול להיות שיש עליו אולי צורה של עטלף?
כן, תמונה של אטלס ציור. כן, ציור של אטלס.
נכון, לא נשמע מאוד סביר בהקשר הזה, לפחות על פניו, אבל כן יכול להיות נכון, בטח מבחינת המבנה התחבירי,
ויכול להיות שהוא פשוט היכה בכדור עם המחבט או עם עטלף, אבל גם זה כבר לא מעניין אותך, כי זה לא קשור בתחביר.
שניהם נרקסיסט, כנראה זה מחבט במקרה הזה, אבל זה סיפור אחר.
על כל פנים. מה שברור במקרה הזה זה שיש.
יש קשר בין הדברים. כן. מתי היינו רוצים לראות נגיד למשל שימוש בגרנד parents לדוגמה אנחנו יכולים לראות שקית ב.
אוקיי, אז להכות אטלס נכון לכשעצמו אולי לא נשמע כמו דבר נורא סביר לעשות.
לא יודע. יש אולי דברים יותר סבירים מבחינת בית הקלפים.
כן, אבל אם אנחנו יודעים שזה אויב, כן או גם להכות עלה.
האמת, זה לא נשמע נורא סביר. נכון גם להכות עלה, אבל זה אולי כבר.
אבל אם היינו יודעים שזה WWE זה ב אז זה כבר נשמע יותר סביר.
נכון? אז ככה שזה בהחלט משנה שזה לא סתם ב אלא Width.
כנל לגבי כדור כן? אז כן, כנל לגבי כדור.
אז אנחנו יכולים בעצם להסתכל ולהשוות את בול עם ב.
אז אולי עקרונית יכול להיות שבאמת מחובר לבול הוא לא דבר כל כך בלתי סביר.
נכון, אבל אולי לב שאומרים זה כבר קצת הופך את זה להיות.
זה עדיין עדיין לא מת. זה הפך את זה עדיין להיות דבר מאוד לא מאוד סביר.
אולי ניקח דוגמה יותר מובהקת. נגיד כאן מה שהתחלנו ממנה כן, שהיא בדיוק מאותה צורה.
Operation patients with fever Operation 9 סקלרוזוס.
אוקיי, אז על פניו שני המשפטים האלה מאוד דומים. כל מה ששונה בהם זה מילה אחת שגם היא הפילוסופית שלה.
בגדול מאוד דומה או זהה, תלוי באיזו סכמה אתם משתמשים, נכון?
אז לכאורה זה אמור לקבל את אותו עץ, אבל או פחות או יותר אותו עץ.
אבל זה שאנחנו מסתכלים על משפט ברור לנו שבמשפט השני זה לא מאוד סביר שהם.
לא יודע. ניתחו אותם, ניתחו אותם עם כאילו במובן של באמצעות חום גבוה באמצעות קדחת נכון או משהו כזה.
כאילו ויב זה לא כל כך סביר שפשוט הוריד פיבר.
הוא מחובר ישירות לאורית בסדר, אבל זה כן סביר שהוא מחובר ל patients.
לעומת זאת Scar פרוז לא סביר שמחובר לפני כן.
סביר שמחובר כן סביר שמכוון מחובר לעופרת.
עכשיו באופן עקרוני Patients להיות מחובר ל wine.
נכון, זה לא נשמע בלתי סביר בפני עצמו.
כן, תתעלמו מהשאר ולראייה מה שהם עשו מה שבא אחריו נכון?
אז הצלע הזאת patients with me היא לא ממש בלתי סבירה, נכון?
למעשה, אולי היא יכולה להיות מאוד סבירה. היא לא סבירה בהקשר כאן, ואחד הרמזים שאומר לנו שהיא לא כשרה.
לא לא סבירה כל כך בהקשר כאן זה לא עצם החיבור בין Patience לוויל.
נכון, אלא זה זה WISE הזה. יש לו Deployment שהוא scale או כאן הופך אותה לשבירה.
זה שאנחנו יודעים שאביב מחובר לפיברו, אוקיי, אז בעצם הקשר הזה?
במילים אחרות הצלע הזאת כן, זה מה שאני מנסה לומר כאן.
הצלע הזאת היא בפני עצמה. הסבירות או הסבירות שלה לא כל כך קשורה לשאלה מה הפאזה Speech של המילה הזאת,
או אפילו מהי המילה הזאת ומה פה תצפית של המילה הזאת או מה היא המילה הזאת או כן או דברים מהסוג הזה.
היא גם לא כל כך קשורה לאורך של הצלע, כי האורך בשני המקרים הוא בדיוק אותו ערך וביניהם שום דבר.
אין לזה גם לא קשורה עם ווינג מטיריאלס. אחד הדברים שכן אפשר להצביע עליו שהיא קשורה אליהם זה השאלה מי הצלע שאומי, הדיפנדר מי עמודי Fire של וויד.
נכון בהקשר אחד Fever בהקשר השני Scar פוקוס בסדר, אז עכשיו אתם זה נותן מוטיבציה?
אני מקווה נכון? למה?
לקרן צ'רלס נכון? וזה שאני יכול לשנות את המשקל האפקטיבית, לשנות את המשפיעים של הצלע בתלות בשאלה אם הצלע שמחוברת אליהם היא סבירה, אולי בסדר.
כן, נכון, מתכת כל סוג של פחמן נכון?
אוקיי, יפה, אז אתה צודק. אז השאלה היא למה לא פשוט לעשות את זה?
למה בלבלתי אתכם עם כל MC PLC שהוא מוגבל ולא יכול לייצר את לא?
או שאני מבולבל או שהתשובה ברורה זה בגלל שמות של מערכות במקום הכל או כלום.
אוקיי, אז בעצם של יעילות גם Spark City זה נכון במרחב.
הרבה מהשאלה הייתה Spark City גם נכון, אבל גם יעילות כאן זה חד משמעית פספוס של יעילות הספארק City.
כנראה אנחנו היינו יכולים לעמוד בו אם היינו יודעים לבחור. את הפיצ'ר פרק של מספיק טוב בכל פה.
אולי לא היינו מכניסים המון פיצ'רים כאן כי זה יותר space.
היינו יכולים להתמודד עם זה. הבעיה העיקרית פה היא איטית. אוקיי, הבעיה הופכת למעשה למעשה היא הופכת להיות מאוד מהר.
כבר נגיד מקרן של Model, למרות שהוא מודל עדיין מאוד מוגבל מבחינת ה setting של ההצבעות יכול לקחת בחשבון.
לבעיה שהיא MP4. אוקיי. בסדר.
עוד דוגמה למודל כזה גם פופולרי. ואם אתם מתעניינים, אתם יכולים להסתכל על.
מאמר שמטרתו מקדונל מצטער. המאמר הקודם, שנה אחר כך, הוציאו מאמר עם In Order Features שהוא נקרא DC בלינג Model.
כן, ואולי אתם לא תופתעו שגם הוא מודל מאוד דומה,
כשההבדל פה היא שאנחנו לוקחים במקום זוגות של צלעות שמהוות שרשרת באורך 2 זוגות של צלעות שיש להם Head משותף.
אוקיי, שבעצם אחים אחד של השני. אז במילים אחרות אני שוכב פה על score, על איזשהו score function שתלוי בשלשות של קודקודים,
כך שגם i יצא לבתי וגם I can יצא לבתי הסדר שהיו בעצם אב משותף לג'יי Kit.
כן, אם נחזור לדוגמה כאן, אוקיי, אז נגיד שמה שהיינו.
שהיינו רוצים להניח שהצלע החסרה כן, נגיד למשל, הצלע הזאת הופכת להיות הרבה יותר סבירה או הרבה פחות סבירה אם אני יודע שהצלע הזאת.
משתתפת ביצ במודל MSC בדיוק מהסיבות שמנינו קודם.
אי אפשר לבטא את זה, אבל מודל כזה ישים.
לינג מודל כן, בדיוק ייתן פה פקטור. נגיד שאני יכול לתת עונש בדיוק מקודם של חמש נקודות.
אם לקחתי את הצלע הזאת אין שום בעיה. אני מוסיף עוד גורם שזכור שנותן.
בהינתן שלושת הקודקודים האלה, איי ג'יי K נותן מינוס חמש לשלישייה הזאת.
אוקיי. או או כל דבר אחר שאתם רוצים להכניס.
גם זה בעיה שהיא אינטראקציה.
וכן, יש כאן שין צ'ק.
אבל כמו הבעיה הקודמת של הקאן Parent, יש אלגוריתמים מקורבים שפותרים אותם.
אז בעצם כל אחד דרכים לעשות את זה ככה.
אני אומר במאמר מוסגר כי זה חומר שלא ניכנס אליו. אחת הדרכים להתמודד עם בעיות מהסוג הזה עם בעיות אופטימיזציה מהסוג הזה.
זה מה שנקרא Integer ליניאל programming שאני לא יודע אם יצא לכם להיתקל בו.
באיזה קורסים למדתם עליו? דלגו, למדתם? אוקיי.
אז כן, אז מי שמכיר Framework של integer פה, גם אם אתם בטח יודעים שזאת בעיה שבאופן עקרוני אלה בעיות שהם NP complete.
אבל. יש אלגוריתמים יעילים שבהרבה מקרים מצליחים לתת קרובים טובים ומה שמאפשר שימוש באותו Structure.
תעשה פתרון שאמרתי קודם. כן, אם אתם זוכרים, הערתי שגם אם יש לנו אלגוריתם היסק לא מדויק אבל בערך מדויק,
עדיין אפשר לקבל אלגוריתם למידה לא רע אם משתמשים בסנקציות פוספט או עם אפוקסי מטריקס, וזה בהחלט משהו שעושים.
מי שמתעניין יותר מוזמן באמת לקרוא את המאמר פה שהפניתי אליו בקטנה.
ופרה 2016. אוקיי, אז באיזה מקרה אם נרצה להשתמש בסיב לנג Model, אז הנה אפשר שוב לחזור למקרה כאן.
יכול להיות שאנחנו רוצים לומר שלהקות עם מחבט, נגיד או משהו כזה הופך להיות סביר או לא סביר אם מדובר בכדור.
אוקיי, כי אם נגיד למשל מדובר בלא יודע משהו שלא מכים אותו כל כך עם מחבט, נגיד למשל חלק מביטוי כמו הידרו.
כן, נכון, מעט כמו בשיר המפורסם כן, אז כן או או שימושים אחרים במילה היט כן, במובנים אחרים שלה אולי יהפכו את זה לפחות סביר שזה נעשה עם מחבט.
אבל האם אנחנו יודעים שמדובר על להכות בכדור? אולי מחבט נשמע כמו אופציה סבירה יותר?
כן. אז דברים מהסוג הזה בהחלט נתפסים.
אם אתם זוכרים, היה לנו עוד סוג של פיצ'רים שדיברנו עליהם בהתחלה, שהם פיצ'רים אפקטיביים ובעצם עדיין לא התייחסנו אליהם.
זה מה שקראנו, כן, וילנץ. פיצ'ר זה הוביל פיצ'ר ערכיות בעברית.
אם נתקלתם בזה שזה בדיוק הרעיון של בעצם להסתכל איזה סוגי דאנס וכמה יש למילה מסוימת, מתוך הנחה שמכונה בהרבה שפות,
שלפחות לחלק מהמילים יש בעצם קונפיגורציות או אוספים של דיפנס שהם סבירים יותר או פחות.
כן, המילה sleep אין. יש לה נושא הרבה פעמים, אבל אין לה מושג אם בכלל המילה [INAUDIBLE].
יש לה הרבה פעמים מושאים וגם לפעמים תיאורי כן אינסטרומנטס תיאורי כלי שמשתמשים בו כמו בלהקות עם מחבט.
המילה הגיב יש לה הרבה פעמים שני מושאים אחד מי שמקבל והשני מה שהתקבל.
כן. בנוסף לנושא כמובן כל הדברים האלה שבאופן עקרוני אנחנו צריכים בשבילם פיצ'רים מסדר יותר גבוה משתיים.
נכון, תלוי כמובן במספר הדיפנדר, אבל אם באופן עקרוני אני רוצה להגיד כן למילה Hit יכול להיות נושא ומושא, אבל לא שני מושאים כנראה כן.
או להגיד אם נגיד למשל לגבי או להגיד לגבי דגים שזה בסדר שיהיו לשני נושאים.
כן, שזה בסדר שיהיו לו שני מושאים. זה בסדר שיהיה לו כמוסה אחד עם תו.
כן, כמו Gave the present, אומר Game Maria Present, אבל שאם גיב הופך להיות פאסיב אוקיי, בלשון סביל,
אז כבר אז כבר לא יכול להיות לו שני מושאים או מאוד לא סביר שיהיה לו שני מושאים, אלא יש לו רק מושא אחד לבטא את כל הדברים האלה.
זה עשוי בעצם לערב סטים. שהם יותר גדולים משתי צלעות.
כן, זה בעצם עשוי לערב סלטים שהם יותר. נגיד למשל עם דיברנו על קשרים בין שלוש צלעות.
נכון, שני מושאים ונושא יש מקרים שבהם גם יש יותר ואז צריכים לעבור לסדר יותר גבוה, יותר ממה שנקרא סדר שני.
צריך לעלות למודלים עוד יותר מורכבים,
אבל הרעיון אותו רעיון מגדירים איזשהו score function שלוקח בחשבון חלק מהקבוצות איזשהו סאב סט שנראה מספיק אינטנסיבי,
אבל אולי לא גדול מדי כדי שהחוסר יעילות הספציפי לא יהרוג אותנו.
אז לוקחים איזשהו סאב קצת יותר גדול של קבוצות קודקודים אפשריות, תוצאות אפשריות ומגדירים עליהם איזשהו פיצ'ר Function ומשם הכל הוא מאוד דומה.
בסדר. מי שמתעניין בתחום הזה של היירו, דר Features ואיך מגלים בכל מיני צורות מעניינות את הקשרים בין הצלעות או איזה סוגי גרפים מרשים?
לא מרשים? האם אפשר מראש לפסול חלק מהעצים כי העצים לא סבירים בשל המבנה?
כל מיני תכונות מבניות שלהם. יש לזה הרבה עבודה מעניינת.
לא ניכנס אליה בקורס הזה, אבל הנה כמה מאמרים מהם בשני העשורים האחרונים, ויש גם רבים נוספים.
אז זה בהחלט נושא מעניין. ואתם המתעניינים מוזמנים להמשיך ולקרוא.
אוקיי, שאלות עד כאן. יפה.
עכשיו אתם בטח תהיתם מה קורה לגבי ייצוגים נוירונים?
נכון? הרי סך הכל התחלנו לדבר על ארמנים. דיברנו על White Media, נסכם כבר נכון ל 2026, או למעשה גם נכון ל 2016 כבר יש 50.
הרי יותר כבד בפיצ'רים מוגדרים ידנית של כל מיני Binary combination כאלה.
האם אנחנו? האם האם הפיצ'רים האלה יכולים להועיל בשביל לבצע את בעיית הניתוח התחבירי?
וכאן באמת עולה תהייה? כאן באמת עולה תהייה שכן.
סליחה, תזכיר לי את שמך אני שכחתי. אוי אוי כן, שהוא יהיה לקודם.
האם זה נכון להשתמש בפיצ'רים האלה? כי הרבה פעמים אפשר לחשוב על פיצ'רים יותר סמנטיים.
כן, שמגדירים מה המשמעות של המילים או מה המובן שמשתמשים בו בהקשר המסוים.
כן, מה שקראנו לקסיקון סמנטית, סמנטיקה, לקסיקון להכניס בעצם את זה שהוא מת, שאפשר לחשוב עליו כנושא יותר או כתחום שהוא יותר.
אנושי, כבד. אולי אפשר לחשוב על זה שכאילו אם התחלנו כן עם אנשי התחביר או איזשהו רובד יותר בסיסי של ניתוח,
אנחנו צריכים קודם לעשות אותו במושגים תחביריים ולא להכניס שיקולים משיקולים סמנטיים שבעצם גם יהפכו את האלגוריתם ליותר כבד.
וגם אולי זה לא הדרך הנכונה קונספטואלית להתמודד עם גוגל.
אז אז בעצם התשובה לזה היא שבעצם יש לזה שתי תשובות.
תשובה אחת היא שבאופן עקרוני אפשר לעשות פירסינג די אפקטיבי.
אנחנו נראה עוד מעט קצת תוצאות אפשר להראות.
אפשר לעשות פרסים די אפקטיבי גם בלי להשתמש בפיצ'רים סמנטית.
פיצ'רים בטקסט יש מאמר מאוד ידוע מ 2003, שבעצם כן, אולי ייתן קצת רקע היסטורי לנושא הזה.
בעצם, היסטורית, באמת זה התחיל. הנושא הזה של ניתוח כן, ניתוח תחבירי אוטומטי באמת, בלי שימוש בפיצ'רים סמנטיים שבגדול היו נחשבים פיצ'רים כבדים יותר,
שגם לא כל כך ידעו בזמנו איך להפיק אותו, ויותר רצו לחשוב על בעצם בעיה של ניתוח תחבירי כמשהו שאמור לשמש כאיזשהו פיגום עבור תהליך סמנטי שיהיה מבוסס עליו.
כן. קולינס, אותו קולינס שדיברנו עליו קודם, עסקתי עוד Perfect One בעבודת הדוקטורט שלו.
שוב, זה רקע היסטורי. אני אומר את זה. מאמר מוסגר למי שמתעניין בתולדות התחום.
כן, אז אותו מייקל קולינס באמצע שנות ה 90 פרסם את עבודת הדוקטורט שלו, שבה הוא בעצם הראה של למדל את מה שנקרא את הבי לפסיקה.
לפי מתי זה האלה? כן, את זה של Patients הוא כנראה דיפנדר.
כן דיפנדר של טוויטר ואו אופ רייטד ודוקטור איזו סאבטקסט של זה.
ואני לא יודע בדברים אחרים הם לא. הוא הראה שבעצם זה פיצ'ר מאוד מאוד אפקטיבי אפילו ביכולות החישוביות וב אלגוריתמיקה שהייתה ידועה לפני שלושים שנה.
כן. הבעיה היא שזה הפך את האלגוריתם להרבה הרבה יותר כבד.
כן, כי עכשיו זה בעצם הכריח את האלגוריתם הזה לשמור איזה שהוא ידע.
מילונים ידע על איזה זוגות מילים מסתדרים, מסתדרות אחת עם השנייה וזה לא מה שהפך את כן את האלגוריתם לשוק.
ובדיוק היום היינו רואים את זה כמשהו קליל מבחינה חישובית.
בזמנו זה היה כבד. אוקיי, דן קליין ב 2003, בעבודת הדוקטורט שלו?
כן, שבע שנים מאוחר יותר הראה שבעצם יש הרבה יתירות בייצוג של קולית, כלומר שכל.
אין צדק בזה שהוא אמר. צריך לעדן את הקטגוריות תחבירית, לעדן אותם לקטגוריות יותר עדינות שיספקו לנו יותר מידע על הקשרים,
על מתי צל לבין מילים סבירה או לא סבירה, אבל שבעצם שמספיק לנו מידע מספיקה לנו.
אז דרגת ביניים זה ספר סי מידי והציג דרך לעשות את זה.
עכשיו מגיע בזאת ומני שאנחנו הולכים לדבר עליו עכשיו 2017.
כן, אז קפצנו קדימה עשור וחצי.
בעצם, מה שהם מראים זה שאם אתה משתמש בייצוג מקסיקלי שמבוסס וויד עם איקס ונייר על מישיגן, הרי כמו רננים שדיברנו עליהם עכשווי.
בעצם יש כאן מידע שאין לו כיום תחליף.
כן. במילים אחרות אלקסה קוסמטיקס, הייצוג הוורדים בדאנס וסוגים מצליחים לתת בוסט די משמעותי בתוצאות.
ואם יש לכם מספיק דאטה כדי לאמן עוד עובדים, כלומר אין לייבל.
הייתה הכוונה של אז כדאי לכם להשתמש בזה.
והנה הרעיון. כן, ונראה לי כבר שזה יהיה הנושא האחרון.
להשאיר עוד קצת חופשים. אז הנה הרעיון הרעיון הוא סך הכל די פשוט, הוא אומר כך.
זאת אומרת, פשוט בהינתן שיש לכם את המשימה, אתם מקבלים משפט.
אתם רוצים להוציא את מבנה? את המבנה התחבירי של המשפט?
מה אתם עושים? דבר ראשון אתם מכניסים את זה לנקודה by arena, מהסוג שראינו לפני שני שיעורים.
הרנן אחד הולך קדימה. כן, מההתחלה עד הסוף.
השני הולך מהסוף. להתחלה מייצרים איזשהו לפרזנטציה של המילה,
שקשורה גם למה שמופיע אחריו ולפניו במשפט בסדר נקרא לזה R עריכת כל מילה מקבלת איזה שהוא וקטור שמייצג אותם בתוך המשפט שבו היא נתונה.
זה מאוד חשוב כי אני לא מייצג רק את זה שהמילה הזאת היא book, אלא מייצג את זה שזה מילה book שהיא באיזה שהיא צורה,
אבל גם מושפע מזה שהיא בתחילת המשפט שאחריה מופיע date flight וכן הלאה.
עכשיו אנחנו הולכים. אז אוקיי, אז זה שלב ראשון עם Congress על גבי הארנה.
מנקודה אנחנו בעצם לוקחים כל אחת מהעיצובים של המילים ואנחנו מזינים אותם לשתי רשתות פשוטות.
כן, Ford נטוורקס. שבעצם מייצרות שני, אבל לאחד מהם נקרא הייצוג של המילה כהד כגרעין והשנייה ייצוג של כיתת אוקיי, אז במילים אחרות אנחנו חושבים עליהם.
כן, כאמור, הכל נפנופי ידיים. זה כמובן deep learning, אז אין לי דרך באמת להוכיח שום דבר,
אבל עקרונית אני חושב עליהם בתור ייצוג של המילה הזאת כהד וורד וייצוג של המילה הזאת כדי Penny וכן הלאה.
לגבי כל המילים במשפט עכשיו יש לנו אוסף של n זוגות נכון לייצוג של המילה כהד ייצוג של המילה כדי פנדות.
מה נעשה? סליחה? מה נעשה?
נגדיר פונקציה בעצם מה שנקרא תבנית ריבועית פונקציה בי אפינית.
כלומר נגדיר פונקציה שמה שהיא עושה זה לוקחת ולומדת משקולות על מכפלות של זוגות פיצ'רים בין אם בד.
אם זה אלה כן, כלומר איקס אחד וואי אחד איקס אחד buy2 איקס אחד וואי שלוש איקס אחד.
כל הקומבינציות כל זוג כן מקבל איזה שהוא משקל פלוס.
יש גם משקלים לכל אחד מהפיצ'רים בפני עצמו.
כן יש כאילו גורם לינארי, סוג של בייס קטן כזה.
כן, פלוס באסטר אמיתי. אבל הוא לא משפיע. וזה בעצם מאפשר לי להגדיר באמצעות Soft Max על גבי הסכומים האלה.
מה שאני יכול זה להגדיר זה בעצם להגדיר את ה score של זה שאיי וג'יי יהיו מחוברים.
כן, טסקו IVIG יהיו מחוברים. כלומר אני מסתכל על כל זוג מילים במשפט.
כן נזין אותם. לגבי find function הזאת, כן לתבנית הריבועית הזאת שלמדתי בעצם עוד סוג של רשת קטנה.
כן, פשוט יש לה צורה מאוד מסויימת פשוטה. אז אני מזין כל פעם מכפלות שלהם במכפלה של H1 עם H1 head עם H2.
Defender נותן לי את score של הצלע.
כן, שבה H2 נמצאת מתחת, היא נמצאת מיידית מתחת לעץ אחד H1 כפול H2 head נותן לי את ה score של צלע בדיוק בכיוון ההפוך.
כן וכן הלאה. לגבי כל הזוגות בסדר אז אני מקבל n בריבוע סכומים כאלה.
ועכשיו לכל מילה יש head אחד בדיוק.
אם אני כולל את האות כן כאן פוטנציאל.
לכל מילה יש בדיוק head אחד, אז אני פשוט עושה סוף מקצה הסכומים האלה ומקבל לכל מילה איזה שהיא התפלגות נכון על פני כל המילים האחרות במשפט.
והסיכוי שכל אחת מהן תהיה אחת ואז מה שהם עושים זה בעצם לוקחים.
כן, אז מה שהם עושים זה בעצם הם לוקחים את זה והם מבצעים.
כן MSC influence אם זה עכשיו מה שחשוב זה שיטת training.
אוקיי, את האימון אתם יכולים לשאול איך הם עושים את האימון של רשת הזאת?
את האימון בגדול הם עושים לגמרי לוקאלית. זאת אומרת, זה כבר לא.
אולי זה structure production במובן הזה שבאים. הם משתמשים בהם MSC אבל זה structure שמאוד חלש במובן הזה שהם מתעלמים זה לגמרי באימות.
הם בעצם לומדים את הבעיה של לבחור עבור מילה את ההד שלה.
לומדים את זה כבעיית קלסי. פיקציה לוקח. לגמרי בסדר.
לוקחים עץ. כל מילה בעץ היא אינסטנט.
מסתכלים על כל המילים האחרות. אחד מהם בטריינינג דאת יודעים שהוא התשובה הנכונה.
לפעמים כל הסיפור עם הרשת שבנויה כאן במילים אחרות איזשהו ייצוג של המילים שאחרי זה פשוט עובר מכפלה בתבנית כזאת ריבועית.
מה שהם מראים במאמר שנייה אחת.
מה שהם מראים במאמר הזה זה שבהינתן שלמדנו את האינקובטור הזה בצורה מספיק אפקטיבית ושהיה לנו מספיק דאטה ותת אותות התעלפות בסטייג שלהם,
למרות שהם בעצם עושים אימון שמתעלם מהמבנה של הבעיה,
אלא מפרק אותה לבעיות של תחזיות של צלע ולכל אחת מהם מאמן בפני עצמה, ולמרות זאת הם מקבלים ציונים טובים.
שאלה למה זה קשור ולמה?
אה, זה לא קשור זה זה המוטציה. סליחה כן אני אוסיף את זה מוטציה כאילו מהספר של ג'ורג פסקין ומני זה פשוט קונקרטי.
ונציה כן, מה שזה פשוט אומר זה שכאילו חוץ מגורם בעצם יש לך What לכל מכפלה של ספורט מנת פה עם קורדינציה פה ויש לך עוד
זווית לכל קורדינציה פה בנפרד ולכל הקואורדינטות פה כאילו ממפה ישר בכל אחת מהקאות יכול להיות קצת בעייתי.
כן. מאיפה? זה פשוט רשת די פשוטה.
כן, תזכור שאת החלק הזה הם בעצם צריכים לאמן מהלייבל data כאילו את העין cover.
אולי אנחנו נראה גם קצת בהמשך, אבל אתה גם יהיה.
אבל באופן עקרוני אתה נגיד יכול לקחת את עם Cover הזה אפילו מאיזשהו סוג של language model.
אנחנו נראה את זה קצת בהמשך הקורס. זאת אומרת, אתה יכול גם להשתמש בהן label data, אבל ממש את דיסקציה הזאת אתה צריך לדעת מה יצא לה הנכונה, מהו ההד הנכון.
אז אתה צריך לייבל די טעתה כאילו אתה. כנראה הם רצו ללכת על משהו שהוא יותר.
אתה יודע, יש לו פחות פרמטרים כדי שהספר לא יגמור אותם.
כן, זה בערך היה שכולם. הם אמרו גם שזה עובד לפחות באופן סביר.
אז כן, בסוף הן שם יותר מדי הוכחות שאתם פעילים ברקע.
כן ולא קיבל פרס אז זה un label. פרסים אולי בן פרסים.
הוא מאוד דומה, פשוט לא קיבל פרסים. הם הפכו את זה לשתי בעיות.
פרס דיקציה לוקה להיות הראשונה שחוזים בה שחוזים בהם מה הם הצלעות שבעצם עושים דרך דיקציה על הצלעות עם MC פרשינג והשנייה עם MC Influence.
כלומר, ועל שבהינתן צלע שהיא כבר חזינו אותה כשייכת לעץ מהו הלייבל הסביר ביותר הוא פשוט מולטי Cluster סטיקי שמה ללייבל שנעשה בפייק ליין.
כן, זה פשוט אסור ברופאי פלינט שעושה את זה אחד אחרי השני. אוקיי, מילה אחרונה תוצאות כן, זה שקף אחרון, קצת תוצאות.
אז במשך הרבה זמן בעיית הפירסינג בעצם אינדיפנדנט, סיפר בריינט מאוחר יותר שלה, הייתה אחת מהן, אני חושב.
הזירות העיקריות שבהם אנשים הציעו וניסו טכניקות לסגירת Medicine.
זאת אומרת, זה הפך להיות מין בנצ'מרק לא רק לתחביב לשם תחביר, אלא הרבה התעסקו בו, כי זאת בעיה שיש לה הגדרה מספיק, כנראה מספיק נוקשה.
כן, מספיק רגיש ויש לך איזשהם, אבל נראה לי שם Practice הזה וכן הלאה.
זה הפך להיות מין Benchmark ושם של פרדיגמה. זה אולי יהיה טוב בשביל פיתוח שיטות לסקירת בדק שם,
אבל פחות טוב באמת כדי לפתח את התחום בגלל שהיה מה שנקרא כן סוג של over פייטינג כן או סוג של קוראים לזה.
היום קוראים לזה היום benchmark סנצ'ורי שכאילו כל פעם יש עוד עבודה ועוד עבודה שמנסה את אותו benchmark.
אז אפילו אם אתה נורא משתדל, בסוף יוצא שאתה בונה משהו נורא תפור כאילו לבן מרק הספציפי,
אבל יעשו את זה בעיקר כדי שיהיה אפשר להשוות באופן יחסית פשוט בין שיטות שונות,
ומה שנבחר היה קורפוס של מבוסס על המאמרים של הוול סטריט ג'ורנל מאזור אמצע שנות ה 80 באנגלית כן, ועבדו על עם דומיין Problems.
הבייסיק MC פרסר קיבל משהו כמו אה סליחה, התכוונתי לרשום שם Whats.
כן. דבר ראשון פשיטה. כנען לייבל הצד שנזכור אני בלדה כי יוסי קיבל באזור.
כן, קצת פחות מ 91. זה אותו מאמר מ 2005 של מקדונלד ואחרים.
שימוש בהייר אורדר Features. הם הגיעו קרוב וכל אינץ הגיעו לסט Modern features.
אוקיי, כלומר, כשמסתכלים על בעצם על רביעיות עד רביעיות של מילים, ראו שאתם רואים שזה הוריד חלק משמעותי.
בעצם זה אולי נראה לכם כמו שני אחוז או שתיים. נקודה אחד אחוז נראה לכם אולי מעט, אבל בעצם זה לא מעט, כי שוב אותו דבר שאחד על הגג חל גם פה.
רוב הצלעות הם די משעממות. כן, לחבר פעם כשהוא אישם לרוט, לחבר זה לנאום שבא אחריו.
רובם הם לא מאוד קשות. בדיוק תשעה אחוזים עד תשע נקודה.
11 אחוזים האלה, שמקדונלד'ס ואחרים נכשלו עליהם ב 2005, הם הרבה מהחלק הכי מעניין והכי אינפורמטיבי של המשפט.
אז בהחלט זה שהצליחו להוריד. יותר מ 20 אחוז מזה זה היה בהחלט מרשים.
דוסט ומנהיג בתוצאה שהייתה נחשבת אז די מדהימה, כאמור באמצעות שימוש לא סתם בהם כאילו first,
אורדר, אפילו first אורדר שממומן לוקאלית כאילו משהו ממש עם פופוליסטי מאוד.
אני כאילו ביחס לקובה קולינס הגיעו לתוצאה הרבה יותר גבוהה שזה באמת לשאלתך.
רועי הם פשוט הראו שם תוצאה שעכשיו אנשים לא כל כך חשבו שסוג כזה של פיצ'רים הוא עד כדי כך אפקטיבי, אבל מסתבר שכן.
אם יש לכם מספיק data computer ובעצם מה שהעלה את השאלה הטבעית האם יש משהו להרוויח גם זה וגם כן, כי לכאורה הם לא סותרים אחד את השני.
אפשר להשתמש בהיי אורדר Features עם פיצ'רים נוירונים נכון, עם איזשהו רשת נוירונים שמייצרת אותם עבודות המשך.
יש כאן דוגמה אחת לעבודה כזאת. מי שמתעניין הראו שכן מקבלים קונסיסטנטי.
גיינס כן, שיפורים עקביים מעל.
כן מעל טעויות זאת ומנהיג אם משתמשים בפיצ'רים יותר גבוהים אבל השיפורים הם כבר קטנים.
כן, מדובר על עשיריות האחוז אפילו במושגי error reduction.
כן, כאילו כמה מתוך הטעות זה מחסל? אז כן, אתם אומרים אוקיי, הטעות היא ארבע נקודה שלוש.
אז בסדר, אז אולי שיפרו 5 אחוזים? כן, סגרו חמישה אחוזים מהטעות.
שבעה אחוזים מהטעות. סך הכל זה קטן, אבל זה כן קונסיסטנטי.
ומכיוון שבסופו של דבר מדובר על Setting די מוזר כן in domain, כלומר שיש לכם training database data מאותו דומיין רק באנגלית.
כן, שכמובן יש הרבה שפות אחרות שעבורם יש הרבה פחות data זמין וצריך להיות יותר להשקיע יותר במודלים נכון באינדקס בייס, כי ה data הוא פחות שפחות.
אז אם אתם לוקחים גם את הדברים האלה בחשבון, בהחלט נראה שיש מה להרוויח מהר יותר Features.
אבל בגלל שמאז סדר גודל של 2020 2021 2022, לצד GPT שלוש, כל התחום השתנה לחלוטין בצורה שנדבר עליה, כנראה בשיעור הבא או זה שאחריו.
אז אני חושב שזה קצת פחות בפוקוס של הקהילה, אבל נראה שבהחלט העבודה Features ולפחות לי נראה לא אמרו את המילה האחרונה.
זהו, זה מה שרציתי להגיד על דיפי הלמן סיפר סינג ונראה לי אפשר לסיים כמה דקות מוקדם.
בשבוע הבא נדבר על תרגום אוטומטי ושם translation ועל Transformer ים וכן נגיע ממש לעבודה של השנים האחרונות.
אז להתראות. במסגרת.
אי אפשר אפילו ממש לא. לצערי זה.
לא הולך כך רציתי לספר, אבל ההצהרה של נשיא ארצות הברית שאני.
שנה. משהו לא? נכון, קורס שכל אחד רוצה להגיד מה הוא רוצה.
אבל את הבעיות האלה לא חשבתי על בריטניה.
האמנתי שאגיע למצב. ממש משוגע.
אבל בדיוק ברגע ששמתי את הפוקוס על זה ניסיתי ללכת למקומות.
עכשיו השאלה שלי. מה עושים?
יש לך עוד משימה ונראה כאילו מה אני מפספסת?
כן יכולים להשתתף במירוץ השקופיות שלהם. רצוי מאוד לשאול אותך כי יש מה אנחנו מפספסים.
האם אנחנו לומדים כל פעם שמועמד לא מתעסק?
יודע? לא, אנחנו בונים אחר כך עוד כמה שבועות בשנה הבאה.
אני חושב שאתם אפילו לא מקבלים הרבה שעות קודם לכן.
אז אז זה בעיקר אפשר להתעסק בו בארבע שפות.
כן. ואז, מטבע הדברים הם יוצאים מהנושא הזה כל הזמן, אז הוא בנוי סביב הדברים הממש עכשווים.
סתם, אנחנו כבר הרבה שנים ואין כזה.
ממש מסתכלים בתצוגת וידאו. זאת אומרת אני לא הולך סתם סתם.
לדעתי אני לא יודע. זה מה שהיה צריך. קצת עניין של תפיסה.
אתה יודע תפיסה כזאת של קורס, אבל אני בתפיסה שלי שזה יותר חשוב לי.
לא, כי כי קשה הרבה יותר להשלים את זה.
כאשר. אבל. בעברית החדשה אין דוגמה שבהם עושים מה שאני מכיר, וזה כאילו מדע פופולרי, אבל אין לי דוגמה שבה יש נוקאאוט יותר חזק.
עכשיו מסתבר שכאילו המודלים נתנו לכל אחד שטח כדוגמה.
לא יודע מאיפה יביא ש. אז ככה, אמרתי כמה שנים קודם, אבל זה חבל, נכון גם לגבי זה.
בוא נגיד, אולי אפילו בעוצמה גדולה מדי. שלא כמו נגיד גם השוק הסיני.
מה שלא היה כן היה היה.
תפרו, תפרו אלגוריתם לכל דבר ספציפי ואז לסופות רעמים הכל היה.
במדינת ישראל של היום זה מעניין.
אתה יודע שקשה בלימודים במכללות? כן, אבל זה מתפיסה.
לפחות אני אגיד לך שכשאני בדוקטורט לפני 15 שנה.
אין בי. אין עכשיו משהו שהוא אפילו לא לגמרי מדעי.
לא פשוט לך לאכול אותו? לא, זה לא כמו מדעי המחשב, כי זה דווקא מה שיפריע להרבה.
מדעי המחשב אני חושב שזה היה תחום. שדווקא המתמטיקה שלו לא הייתה מספיק מתוחכמת.
כאילו בבייג'ין השתמשו בכל מיני דברים לטרנספורמציה וכל מיני דברים כאילו.
כן, וצריך לעשות דברים סופר סופר סופר מנטליים, כאילו למצוא אנשים, למצוא כוחות להיכנס טרנספורמציות ריצ'י ואני מאוד מאוד ספציפית.
כן, אבל כאילו הייתי שם יותר במתמטיקה אז יותר אז זה יותר בית ספר על זה וזהו.
טוב, זה אני הולך. קצת קשה להסתכל 15 שנה אחורה ולהיזכר איך השבוע הזה לא.
עזוב שנייה את השאלה שאתה מחוללת מה קורה בזה שדווקא באמת אדם עם דברים חשובים בהיסטוריה, אתה משתמש בהם למקומות?
משפחת. לומדים איזה כלי נשק חשוב, או כי משהו שיכול להגיד עובד במה אמרו לידי מובילי דעה.
לא זכור לי סודן של חצי אחוז מהצבא, שם אמר שהם משתמשים בדברים כאלה כי זה פשוט הרבה יותר מהיר.
כאילו אתה לא יכול להשוות בכלל. אתה יודע הבדלי שפה, אפילו נתקלתי איך קוראים לזה.
מי שיוכל להפתיע בגרסאות הניידות עדיין מדובר על שינוי מהיר.
כן קראתם כי אנשים כבר הבינו את זה עכשיו. ממש קטלני כזה אתה יודע.
9. לא בשבילי ודחה סתם והסתפק בטיסה.
צודקת. אין מה להשוות לבידוק הטחורים.
נוכחתי בגדול בסקר פייס ב 48 דרך מה שעושה צוות פייפר לעניין סנודן הוא עצום, אבל אתה כמובן דוחף אותו.
כן, זה לא שאתה עושה לו אינדקסים מתוחכם. לב זה לא השאלה שלי.
כן, אתה עושה כל מיני דברים כאילו כדי לייעל את זה. אז אתה שר?
זה לא מזכיר לך? לא, אבל אני חושב שזה יותר עבר לדברים שבהם אתה צריך להיות מאמין.
זהו, שבהרבה תאגידים כן, בארץ זה נכון.
אתה רוצה לקנות מכשיר קצה באיזה ערוצים שלא?
כן כן זה. אני לא יודע בדיוק מה הם עושים, כאילו אני אומר זה על דבר טיסה, אבל מה שאני אומר צריך לפעמים מה לעשות.
צריך להכניס כאילו כזה סוג של לוגיקה במכשירים מאוד קטנים.
נכון לעשות רעש כאילו, אולי אפילו הגפיים התחתונות.
יש משהו שכזה גורמים לכאוס כזה?
אז כזה ערב כזה בצרפתית זה אולי בית חולים פרטיים עם הדרכה נכון?
כל מיני דברים שקיימים היום באירופה היום אני מפעיל את זה רק על נכון.
לא לא. ספר, אבל זה לא מפיל את זה על החלוקה.
אז לפי מה שאני אז זה אף פעם הרבה זמן לא ראיתי דבר כזה בצד של האישי שלי, ואני לא מסוגל להריץ גם דברים בגודל מילים כמו.
זה לא דומה. יש לך קול נחמד?
כן, אז זה לא כזה נורא טוב. טוב לדעת. תודה רבה.
זה לא זמן מעניין להקשיב לאנשים ממש. אני אשמח אם להוסיף את המסמך שקופית.
אה, כי היום כאילו זה קצת כאילו פשוט שיש את זה יותר עושה לי סדר.
עושה. תודה רבה.